the following is a conversation with Sam
Harris his second time on the podcast as
I said two years ago when I first met
and spoke with Sam he's one of the most
influential pioneering thinkers of our
time as the host of The Making Sense
podcast creator of the waking up app and
the author of many seminal books on
human nature and the human mind
including the end of Faith the moral
landscape lying Free Will and waking up
in this conversation besides our mutual
fascination with AGI and free will we do
also go deep into controversial
challenging topics of Donald Trump
Hunter Biden January 6th vaccines lab
leak Kanye West and several key figures
at the center of public discourse
including Joe Rogan and Elon Musk both
of whom have been friends of Sam and
have become friends of mine
somehow an amazing life trajectory that
I do not deserve in any way and in fact
believe is probably a figment of my
imagination
and if it's all right please allow me to
say a few words about this personal
aspect of the conversation of discussing
Joe Elon and others
was been weighing heavy on my heart
since the beginning of the pandemic now
three years ago is that many people I
Look to for wisdom in public discourse
stop talking to each other as often with
respect humility and love when the world
needed those kinds of conversations the
most
My Hope Is that they start talking again
they start being friends again they
start noticing the humanity that
connects them that is much deeper than
the disagreements that divide them
so let me take this moment to say with
humility and honesty why I look up to
and I'm inspired by Joe Elon and Sam
I think Joe Rogan is important to the
world as a voice of compassion and
curiosity and open-mindedness to ideas
both the radical and mainstream
sometimes with humor sometimes with
brutal honesty always pushing for more
kindness in the world
I think Elon Musk is important to the
world as an engineer leader entrepreneur
and human being who takes on the hardest
problems that face humanity and refuses
to accept the constraints of
conventional thinking that made the
solutions to these problems seem
impossible
I think Sam Harris is important to the
world as a Fearless Voice who fights for
the pursuit of Truth against growing
forces of echo Chambers and audience
capture taking unpopular perspectives
and defending them with rigor and
resilience
I both celebrate and criticize all three
privately and they criticize me usually
more effectively for which I always
learn a lot and always appreciate most
importantly there is respect and love
for each other as human beings the very
thing that I think the world needs most
now in a time of division and chaos
I will continue to try to mend divisions
to try to understand not to ride to turn
the other cheek if needed to return hate
with love
sometimes people criticize me for being
naive cheesy simplistic all of that
I know I agree
but I really am speaking from the heart
and I'm trying
this world is too [__] beautiful not
to try in whatever way I know how
I love you all
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Sam Harris
what is more effective at making a net
positive impact on the world empathy or
Reason
it depends on what you mean by empathy
there are two at least two kinds of
empathy there's the
the cognitive form which is
you know I would argue even a species of
of reason it's it's just understanding
another person's point of view you know
you understand
why they're suffering or why they're
happy or what you know we just you have
a theory of mind
about another human being that is is
accurate and so you can
you can navigate uh in relationship to
them more effectively
um and then there's another layer
entirely not incompatible with that but
just distinct which is what people often
mean by empathy which is more
a kind of emotional contagion right like
you feel depressed and I begin to feel
depressed along with you because you
know it's just it's contagious right I I
you know we're so close and I'm so
concerned about you and your problems
become my problems and it bleeds through
right now I think both of those
capacities are very important but
um the emotional contagion piece
uh and this is not really my thesis this
is something I have more or less learned
from from Paul Bloom
um
the psychologists who wrote a book on
this topic titled against empathy
um the emotional social contagion piece
is a bad guide rather often for ethical
behavior and ethical intuitions oh boy
and uh because I'll give you the clear
example of this which is
uh we
find
stories with a single identifiable
protagonist who we can effortlessly
empathize with
far more compelling than data right so
if I tell you you know this is the
classic case of the little girl who
falls down a well right you know this is
some Somebody's Daughter you see the
parents uh distraught on television uh
you hear her Cries From the Bottom of
the well the whole country stops I mean
this was an example of this you know 20
25 years ago I think where it was just
wall-to-wall on CNN this is just the
perfect use of CNN it was you know 72
hours or whatever it was of continuous
coverage of just extracting this girl
from a well
so we effortlessly pay attention to that
we care about it we will donate money
toward it I mean it's just it Marshals
100 of our compassion and altruistic
impulse
um whereas if you hear that there's a
genocide raging in some country you've
never been to and never attended to go
to and the numbers don't make a dent and
the and we find
the story boring and we'll change the
channel in the face of a genocide right
it doesn't matter and it literally it
perversely it could be 500 000 little
girls have fallen down wells in that
country and we still don't care right so
um it's uh you know many of us have come
to believe that this is a bug rather
than a feature of our moral psychology
and so the the empathy plays an
unhelpful role there so ultimately I
think
when we're making big decisions about
what we should do and how to mitigate
human suffering and what's worth valuing
and how we should protect those values
um
I think reason is the better tool but
it's not that I would want to dispense
with any part of empathy either well
there's a lot of tangents to go on there
but briefly to mention you've recently
talked about effective altruism on your
podcast I think you mentioned some
interesting statement I'm going to
horribly misquote you but
that you'd rather live in a world like
it doesn't really make sense but you'd
rather live in a world where you care
about maybe your daughter and son more
than 100 people that live across the
world something like this like where the
calculus is not always perfect but
somehow it makes sense to live in a
world where it's irrational in this way
and yet empathetic in the way you've
been discussing right I'm not sure what
the right answer is there or even
whether there is one right answer there
could be multiple you know Peaks on on
this part of the moral landscape but so
the the opposition is between an ethic
that's articulated by you know someone
like the Dalai Lama right or really any
exponent of of
um you know classic Buddhism would say
that sort of the ultimate enlightened
ethic is true dispassion with respect to
friends and strangers right so that you
would the you know the mind of the
Buddha would be
truly dispassionate you would love and
care about all people equally
and by that light it seems some kind of
ethical failing or at least you know
failure of of to really fully actualize
compassion in the limit or you know
enlightened wisdom in the limit
um to care more or even and much more
about your kids than the kids of other
people or and to prioritize your your
energy in that way right so you spend
all this time trying to figure out how
to keep your kids healthy and happy and
you'll attend to their minutest concerns
and however superficial and and again
there's a genocide raging in Sudan or
wherever and it takes up less than one
percent of your bandwidth I'm not sure
it would be a better world if everyone
was running the Dalai Lama program there
I think some prioritization of
one's nearest and Dearest ethically
might be optimal because we will all be
doing that and we'll all be doing that
in
a circumstance where we have certain
norms and and laws and and other
structures that Force us to be
dispassionate where that matters right
so like when I go to
when my daughter gets sick I have to
take her to to a hospital
you know I really want her to get
attention right and I'm worried about
her more than I'm worried about everyone
else in the lobby but the truth is I
actually don't want a totally corrupt
hospital I don't want a hospital that
treats my daughter better than anyone
else in the lobby because she's my
daughter and I have you know bribed the
guy at the door or whatever you know the
guy's a fan of my podcast or whatever
the thing is you don't want starkly
corrupt unfair situations
and when you're when you sort of get
pressed down the hierarchy of Maslow's
needs you know individually and and
societally
a bunch of the bunch of those variables
change and they change for the worse
understandably but yeah when things are
when everyone's corrupt and it's you're
you're in a state of of uh Collective
emergency you know you've got a Lifeboat
problem you're scrambling to get into
the Lifeboat yeah then then fairness and
norms and and
um the you know the the other vestiges
of civilization
begin to get stripped off we can't
reason from those emergencies to normal
life I mean a normal life we want
Justice we want fairness we want we're
all better off for it even when the
spotlight of our concern is focused on
the people we know the people who are
friends the people who are family people
we we have good reason to care about
we still by default want a system that
protects the the interests of strangers
too and and we know that generally
speaking interested in in game theoretic
terms we're all going to tend to be
better off in a fair system than a
corrupt one one of the failure modes of
empathy is
our susceptibility to anecdotal data
just a good story yeah will get us to
not think clearly but what about empathy
in the context of just discussing ideas
with other people and then there's a
large number of people like in this
country
you know red and blue half the
population believes certain things on
immigration or on the response to the
pandemic or any kind of controversial
issue even if if the election was fairly
executed
having an empathy for their world view
trying to understand where they're
coming from not just in the explicit
statement of their idea but the entirety
of like the roots from which their ideas
thumbs that kind of empathy while you're
discussing ideas what is in your Pursuit
Of Truth having empathy for the
perspective of a large number of other
people
versus Raw mathematical reason I think
it's important but I just it only takes
you so far right it doesn't it doesn't
get you to truth right it's not the
truth is not a
is not decided by you know Democratic
principles and
um certain people believe things for
understandable reasons but those reasons
are nonetheless bad reasons right they
don't scale they don't generalize
they're not reasons anyone should adopt
for themselves or or respect you know
epistemologically and yet their their
circumstance is understandable and it's
something you can care about right and
so yeah like let me just take I think
there's many examples of this you might
be thinking of but
and the one one that comes to mind is
I've been super critical of trump
obviously and
um I've been super critical of certain
people for endorsing him or not
criticizing him when he really made it
you know patently obvious who he was you
know if there had been any doubt
initially there was no doubt when we
have a sitting president who's not not
um agreeing to a peaceful transfer of
power right so
um
I'm I'm critical of all of that and yet
the fact that
many millions of Americans didn't see
what was wrong with Trump or bought into
the
um didn't see through his con right I
mean they bought into the idea that he
was a brilliant businessman who who
might just be able to change things
because he's so unconventional and so
you know his heart is in the right place
you know he's really a man of the people
even though he's a you know gold-plated
everything in his life
um
they bought the myth somehow of you know
the largely because they had seen him on
television for
almost a decade and a half uh pretending
to be this genius businessman who could
get things done
um
it's understandable to me that many very
frustrated people who have not had their
hopes and dreams actualized
uh who have been
the victims of globalism and and uh
many other you know current trends uh
it's understandable that they would
be confused and and and not see the
liability of electing a grossly
incompetent morbidly narcissistic person
into the into the the presidency
um so I don't so which is to say that I
don't blame there are many many millions
of people who I don't necessarily blame
for the Trump phenomenon but I can
nonetheless bemoan the phenomenon as as
indicative of you know very bad
uh State of Affairs in our society right
so it's it's there's two levels to it I
mean one is I think you have to call a
spade a spade when you're talking about
how things actually work and what things
are are likely to happen or not but then
you can recognize it people are have
very different life experiences and and
yeah I mean I think empathy and you know
probably the better word for what I
would hope to embody there is compassion
right like really you know you
to really wish people well you know and
really wish you know strangers well
effortlessly wish them well I mean to
realize that you there is no opposition
between in the at bottom there's no real
opposition between selfishness and
selflessness because wise selfishness
really takes into account
other people's happiness I mean what you
know which do you do you want to live in
a society where you have everything but
most other people have nothing
uh or do you want to live in a society
where you're surrounded by happy
creative self-actualized people who are
having their hopes and dreams realized I
think it's obvious that the second
Society is much better however much you
can guard your good luck
but what about having empathy for
certain principles that people believe
for example
the the pushback the other perspective
on this because you said bought the myth
of trump as the great businessman there
could be a lot of people that are
supporters of trump who could say
that Sam Harris bought the myth that we
have this government
of the People by the people that
actually represents the people as
opposed to a bunch of Elites who are
running a giant bureaucracy that is
corrupt that is feeding themselves and
they're actually not representing the
people and then here's this Chaos Agent
Trump who speaks off the top of his head
yeah he's flawed in all this number of
ways he's a more comedian than he is a
presidential type of figure and he's
actually creating the kind of chaos
that's going to shake up this
bureaucracy shake up the elites that are
so uncomfortable because they don't want
the world to know about the game that
got running on everybody else so that's
yeah that's the kind of perspective that
they would take and say yeah there's
these flaws that Trump has but this is
necessary I agree with the first part of
it so I haven't bought the myth that
it's uh
you know it truly representative
democracy in in the way that we would
you might idealize
um
and
you know on some level I mean this is a
different conversation but in some level
I'm not even sure how much I think it
should be right like I'm not sure
uh we want in the end
everyone's opinion given equal weight
about you know just what we should do
about anything and I include myself in
that I mean there are many topics around
which
I don't deserve to have a strong opinion
because I don't know what I'm talking
about right or what I would be talking
about if I had a strong opinion so
um
and I think we'll probably get to that
to some of those topics because I've
declined to have certain conversations
on my podcast just because I think I'm
the wrong person to have that
conversation right because and and it's
um and I think it's important to see
those
bright lines in in one's life and in in
the moment politically
uh and ethically so yeah I think
um so leave aside the the viability of
democracy uh but I I'm I'm under no
illusions that all of our institutions
are you know worth preserving precisely
as they have been up into the moment
this great orange wrecking ball came
swinging through our lives but
I just It Was a Very Bad Bet to elect
someone who is grossly incompetent and
um or worse than incompetent
um genuinely malevolent in his
selfishness right I think and this is
something we know based on literally
Decades of him being in the public eye
right he's not as he's not a public
servant in any normal sense of that term
and he couldn't possibly give an honest
or sane answer to the question the
question you asked me about empathy and
reason and and like how should we you
know what should guide us
um
I I genuinely think he is missing some
necessary moral and and psychological
tools right and this this is I can feel
compassion for him as a human being
because I think having those things is
incredibly important and genuinely
loving other people is incredibly
important and and knowing what all
that's about is is that's really the
good stuff in life and I I um I think
he's missing a lot of that but I think
we we don't want to promote people to to
the highest positions of power in our
society who are far outliers in
in pathological terms right we want them
to be far outliers in in if in the best
case in wisdom and compassion and some
of the things you've some of the topics
you've brought up I mean we want someone
to be deeply informed we want someone to
be
um
unusually curious unusually alert to how
they may be wrong or getting things
wrong consequentially he's none of those
things and insofar as we're going to get
normal mediocrities in that role which I
think you know is often the best we
could expect let's get normal
mediocrities in that role not uh you
know once in a generation
narcissists and
um
frauds I mean it is like the let me just
take honesty as a single variable right
I think you want yeah yes it's possible
that
most politicians lie at least some of
the time I don't think that's a good
thing I think people should be gen you
know generally honest
um even to a fault
yes there are certain circumstances
where line I think is necessary it's
kind of on a Continuum of self-defense
and violence so it's like if you're
gonna you know if the Nazis come to your
door and ask you if you've got Anne
Frank in the attic I think it's okay to
lie to them
um
but uh
you know Trump there's I arguably
there's never been a person in that
anyone could name in in human history
who's lied with with that kind of
velocity
um I mean it's just it was it was a just
a blizzard of Lies Great and Small you
know to to pointless and and to and
effective but it was just
it
it says something
uh fairly alarming about our society
that a person of that character got
promoted and so uh yes I have compassion
and concern for for half of the society
who didn't see it that way and that's
going to sound elitist and and uh
and smug or something for anyone who's
who's on that side listening to me but
um it's genuine I mean I understand that
like like I barely have the I'm like one
of the luckiest people in the world and
I barely have the bandwidth to pay
attention to half the things I should
pay attention to in order to have an
opinion about half the things we're
going to talk about right so how much
less bandwidth to somebody who's working
two jobs or you know a single mom who's
who's you know raising you know
multiple kids you know even a single kid
it's just it's unimaginable to me that
people have the bandwidth to to Really
track this stuff and so then they jump
on social media and they they see they
get inundated by misinformation and they
see what their favorite influencer just
said
um and now they're worried about
vaccines and they're it's just it's
we're living in an environment where our
in the information space has become so
corrupted and we've built machines to to
further corrupt it you know I mean we've
built a business model for the internet
that it further corrupts it uh so it's
it is just
um
it's chaos in informational terms and
I don't fault people for being confused
and impatient and uh at the at their
wit's end and
um yes Trump was a an enormous [__] you
to The Establishment and and that's that
was understandable for many reasons to
me Sam Harris the great Sam Harris is
somebody I've looked up to for a long
time
as a beacon of voice of reason and
there's this meme on the internet and I
would love you to steal man the case for
it and against that Trump broke Sam
Harris's brain
that there's something is
disproportionately to the actual impact
that Trump had on our society he had
an impact on the div on the ability of
balanced calm rational Minds to see the
world clearly to think clearly you being
one of the beacons of that is there is
there a degree to which he broke your
brain
uh well Otherwise Known As Trump
derangements
yeah I mean I think Trump derangement
syndrome is a very clever meme because
it it just uh throws the you know the
problem back on the person who's
criticizing Trump but in truth the true
Trump derangement syndrome was not to
have seen how dangerous and divisive it
would be to promote someone like Trump
to that position of power and to not and
in the in the final moment not to see
how uh
untenable it was
to still support someone who you know a
sitting president who was not committing
to a peaceful transfer of power I mean
that was if if that wasn't a bright line
for you you have been deranged by
something uh because that was you know
the that was one minute to midnight for
our democracy as far as I'm concerned
and I think it really was but for
the the Integrity of a few people that
we didn't suffer some real
constitutional crisis and and real
emergency you know after January 6. I
mean if Mike Pence had caved in and
decided to non-certify the election
right uh if it literally you can count
on two hands the number of people who
held things together at that moment and
so it was so it wasn't for want of
trying on Trump's part that we we um
didn't succumb to some you know real
truly Uncharted uh uh catastrophe with
our democracy so the fact that that
didn't happen
is not a sign that those of us who were
worried that it was
so close to happening were exaggerating
the problem I mean it's like you know
you almost got run over by a car but you
didn't and so you know you're the fact
that you're adrenalized and you're
thinking you know but boy that was
dangerous I probably shouldn't you know
you know wander in the middle of the
street uh with my eyes closed
um you weren't wrong to feel that you
really had a problem right
um
and came very close to something truly
uh terrible so I think that's where we
were and I think we shouldn't do that
again right so the fact that he's he's
still he's coming back around as
potentially a viable candidate you know
I'm not spending much time thinking
about it frankly because it's you know
I'm I'm waiting for the moment where it
requires some thought
um I mean it did
it took up
uh I don't know how many podcasts I
devoted to the topic
it wasn't that I mean it wasn't that
many in the end you know against the the
number of podcasts I I devoted to other
topics but there are people who look at
Trump and just find him funny
entertaining not especially threatening
is like not a you know just it's just
good fun to see somebody who's like
who's just not taking anything seriously
and it's just just putting a you know a
stick in the wheel of of business as
usual again and again and again and
again
um
and they don't really see anything much
at stake right it doesn't really doesn't
really matter if we don't support NATO
it doesn't really matter if he says he
trusts Putin more than our intelligence
Services uh I mean none of this is it
doesn't matter if he's on the one hand
saying that he loves uh
the leader of North Korea and on the
other threatening is threatens to to you
know bomb them back to the Stone Age
right on Twitter
it's all it all can be taken in the
spirit of kind of reality television
it's like this is just this is the part
of the movie that's just fun to watch
right and
I understand that I can even inhabit
that space for a few minutes at a time
but
there's a deeper concern that we're in
the process of entertaining ourselves to
death right that we're just not taking
things seriously and this is it's a
problem I've had with several other
people we might name who just who just
appear to me to be goofing around at
scale and they lack a kind of moral
seriousness I mean they're touching big
problems where lives hang in the balance
but they're just [__] around and
I think they're really important
problems that we have to get our head
straight around
and we need you know it's not to say
that that institutions don't become
corrupt I think they do and I think and
I'm quite worried that you know both
about the the loss of trust in our
institutions and the
the fact that trust has eroded for good
reason right that they have become less
trustworthy I I think you know they've
become infected by
you know political ideologies that are
not truth tracking I mean I I worry
about all of that
um
but I just think the we need
institutions we need to rebuild them we
need
we need experts who are real experts we
need to Value expertise over
you know amateurish speculation and
conspiracy thinking and just you know
and [__] the kind of amateur
speculation we're doing on this very
podcast
I'm usually alert to the moments where
I'm
just guessing or where I actually feel
like I'm just talking from within my
wheelhouse and I try to Telegraph that a
fair amount with people
[Music]
um
so yeah I mean it but it's not
it's different like I mean you you can
invite someone onto your podcast who's
an expert if that's something that
you're you you're not an expert
about and then you
you in the process of getting more
informed yourself your your audience is
getting more informed so you're asking
smart questions and you might be pushing
back at the margins
but you know that when push comes to
shove on that topic you really don't
have a basis to have a a strong opinion
and
if you were going to form a a a strong
opinion that was this counter to the
expert you have in front of you it's
going to be by deference to some other
expert who you've brought in or who
you've heard about or whose work you've
read or whatever but there's a paradox
to
how we value Authority in science that
most people don't understand and I think
we should at some point unravel that
because it's the basis
for a lot of public confusion and
frankly it's a basis for a lot of you
know criticism I've received on these
topics whereas you know people think
that I'm a
you know I I'm against Free Speech or
I'm an establishment chill or it's it's
like I just think I'm a credentialist I
just think people with phds from ivy
league universities should you know run
everything
it's not true but there's a ton of confu
there's a lot to cut through to get to
Daylight there because people are
um
very confused about how we value
Authority in the service of rationality
generally you've talked about it but
it's just interesting the intensity of
feeling you have you've you've had this
famous phrase about Hunter Biden and
children in the basement can you just
revisit this case so let me
let me give another perspective on the
situation of January 6th and Trump in
general
it's possible that January 6th and
things of that nature revealed that our
democracy is actually pretty fragile
and then Trump is not a malevolent an
ultra competent malevolent figure but
it's simply a jokester
and he just by creating the chaos
revealed that it's all pretty fragile
because you're a student in history and
there's a lot of people like Vladimir
Lennon Hitler who are exceptionally
competent at controlling power
at being Executives and taking that
power controlling the generals
controlling all the figures involved and
certainly not tweeting but working in
the shadows behind the scenes to gain
power and they did so extremely
confidently and that is how they were
able to gain power the the pushback with
Trump is was doing none of that
he was creating what he's very good at
creating drama
sometimes for humor's sake sometimes for
drama's sake and simply reveal that our
democracy is fragile and so he's not
this uh once in a generation horrible
figure once in a generation narcissist
no I I don't think he's he's a
a truly scary Sinister you know
putin-like or you know Hitler much less
hitler-like figure not at all I mean
he's not ideological he doesn't care
about anything beyond himself so it's
not
um
no no he's much less scary than any
really scary you know totalitarian right
I mean and he's he's more Brave New
World than 1984. this is what you know
Eric Weinstein never stops um
badgering me about but you know he's
still wrong Eric
um you know I I can you know my analogy
for Trump was that he's an evil Chauncey
Gardener I don't know if you remember
the the
um the the book or the film being there
uh with it with Peter Sellers
um but you know Peter Sellers is this
Gardener who really doesn't know
anything
um but he gets recognized as this wise
man and he gets promoted to immense
power in Washington because he's
speaking in these kind of in a semblance
of wisdom he's got these very simple
aphorisms or it would seem to be
aphorisms he's just talking all he cares
about is gardening he's just talking
about his garden all the time but you
know he'll say something but yeah you
know in the spring you know the new
shoots will will Bloom and people read
into that some kind of Genius you know
Insight politically and so he gets
promoted and so that's that's the joke
of the film for me Trump has always been
someone like an evil Chauncey Gardner
he's he's
not to say he's totally yes he has a
certain kind of Genius he's got a genius
for creating a spectacle around himself
right he's got a genius for getting the
the eye of the media always coming back
to him
um but it it's only it's a kind of
it's a kind of you know self-promotion
that only works if you actually are
truly Shameless and don't care about
having a reputation for anything that
that I or you would want to have a
reputation for right it's like it's pure
the pure pornography of attention right
and he just wants more of it
um I think that truly depressing and
genuinely scary thing was that
we have a country that at least half of
the country given how
uh
broken our society is in many ways we
have a country that didn't see anything
wrong with that or bringing someone
who's uh who obviously doesn't know what
he should know to be president
and who's obviously not a good person
right obviously doesn't care about
people can't even pretend to care about
people really right in a credible way
um
and so I mean this if there's a silver
line into this it it's it's along the
lines you just sketched it shows us how
vulnerable our system is to a truly
brilliant and Sinister figure right I
mean like a I I think we are
um we really dodged a bullet yeah
someone far more competent
and conniving and ideological could have
exploited our system in a way that Trump
didn't and I and that's um yeah so if if
we
plug those holes eventually
um that would be a good thing and he
would have done a good thing for our
society right I mean one of the things
we realized
and I think nobody knew I mean I
certainly didn't know it and I didn't
hear anyone talk about it
is how much our system
relies on Norms rather than laws yes
civility yeah it's just like it's it's
quite possible that he never did
anything illegal you know truly a truly
illegal I mean I think he probably did a
few illegal things but like illegal such
that he really should be thrown in jail
for it you know
um at least that remains to be seen
so all of the chaos all of the you know
all of the
diminishment of our stature in the world
all of the Just the the opportunity
costs of spending years focused on
nonsense
um
all that was just Norm violations
all that was just that was just all a
matter of not saying the thing you
should say but that doesn't mean they're
insignificant right it's not that it's
like it's not illegal for a sitting
president to say
no I'm not going to commit to a peaceful
transfer of power right we'll wait and
see whether I win if I win
it was the election was was was valid if
I lose it was fraudulent right but
aren't those
humorous perturbations to our system of
Civility such that we know where the
limits are and now we start to think
that and have these kinds of discussions
but that wasn't a humorous perturbation
because he did everything he could
granted he wasn't very competent but he
did everything he could to try to steal
the election I mean the irony is he
claimed to have an election stolen from
him all the while doing everything he
could to steal it declaring it
fraudulent in advance trying to get the
votes to to not be counted as the
evening wore on knowing that they were
going to be disproportionately Democrat
Democrat votes
um because of the the you know because
of the position he took on mail-in
ballots I mean all of it was fairly
calculated
the whole circus of of of you know the
clown car that crashed into you know
Four Seasons Landscaping right and and
he got Rudy Giuliani with his hair dying
you got Sydney Powell and all these
gross incompetent people lying as freely
as they could breathe about election
fraud right and all these things are
getting thrown out by you know
Republican largely Republican election
officials and Republican judges
um it wasn't it wasn't for want of
trying that he didn't maintain his power
in this country he really tried to steal
the presidency he just was not competent
and the people around him weren't
competent so that's a good thing and
it's worth not letting that happen again
but he wasn't competent so he didn't do
everything he could well he did
everything he could he didn't do
everything that could have been done by
someone more competent
right but the the tools you have as a
president you could do a lot of things
you can declare emergencies especially
doing covid you could postpone the
election you can create military
conflict that you know any kind of
reason to postpone the election there's
there's a lot of what he tried to do
things and he would have to have done
those things through other people and
they're people who refuse to do those
things or people who said they would
quit they would they would quit publicly
right I mean this you start again there
are multiple books written about uh all
in the last hours of of this presidency
and the details are shocking in what he
tried to do and tried to get others to
do and it's awful right I mean it's it's
just awful that we were that close
to something
um
to to a true unraveling of our political
process and it's the only time in our
lifetime that anything like this has
happened and
um is deeply embarrassing right for uh
you know on the world stage it's just
like we looked like a Banana Republic
there for a while and
where the lone superpower it's a bit
it's it's not good right and so we
shouldn't like there's no there's no the
I the people who thought well we just
need to shake things up and this is a
great a great way to shake things up and
having people you know storm our capital
and smear [__] on the walls that's just
more shaking things up right it's all
just for the lulls
um there's a nihilism and cynicism to
all of that which again in certain
people it's understandable
you know frankly it's not understandable
if you've got a billion dollars and
you're you you know have a compound in
Menlo Park or whatever it's like there
are people who are cheerleading this
stuff who shouldn't be cheerleading this
stuff and who know that they can get on
their Gulf Stream and fly to their
compound in New Zealand if everything
goes to [__] right so there's a cynicism
to all of that that I think we should be
deeply critical of but what I'm trying
to understand is not
and analyze is not the behavior of this
particular human being but the effect it
had in part on the division between
people as to me the degree the meme
of Sam Harris's brain being broken by
Trump represents
you're like the person I would look to
to bridge the division
well I don't think there is
something profitably to be said
to someone who's truly captivated by the
the the personality Cult of trumpism
right like there's nothing that I'm
going to say to
there's no conversation I'm going to
have with Candace Owens say about Trump
that's going to converge on something
reasonable right you don't think so no I
mean I've tried I haven't tried with
Candace I've tried with you know many
people who
are in that particular orbit I mean I've
I've had conversations with people who
won't admit that there's anything wrong
with Trump anything so I'd like to push
for the empathy versus reason because
when you operate in a space of Reason
yes
but I think there's a lot of power
in you showing and you Sam Harris
showing that you're willing to see the
good qualities of trump publicly showing
that
I think that's the way to win over okay
but he has so few of them he has fewer
good qualities than any virtually anyone
I can name right but so he he's funny he
I'll grant you that he's funny he's he's
a good Entertainer there's others look
at just policies and actual impacts yeah
I've admitted that no no so like so I've
admitted that many of his policies I
agree with
many many of us probably so uh
probably more often than not at least on
balance I agree so I I agreed with his
policy that you know we should take
China seriously as an adversary right
and
um I think I mean again that you have to
there's a lot of fine print to a lot of
this because the way he talks about
these things and and many of his motives
that are obvious or things that I um
don't support but I'm gonna take
immigration I think there's
it's obvious that we should have control
of our borders right like I I don't see
the argument for not having control of
our borders we should let in who we want
to let in and we should keep out who we
want to keep out and we should have a
sane immigration policy so
um I don't I didn't necessarily think it
was a priority to build the wall but I
didn't I never criticized the impulse to
build the wall because if you know tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands of
people are coming across that border and
we are not in a position to know who's
coming
that seems untenable to me so
um and I can recognize that many people
in our society
are on balance the victims of
immigration
because and there is a in in many cases
a zero-sum contest between the interests
of actual citizens and the interests of
immigrants right so I think we should
have a we should have control of our
borders we should have a sane and
compassionate immigration policy we
should have we should let in refugees
right so I you know Trump on refugees
was terrible
um but
no like I would say 80 of the policy
concerns people
uh celebrated in him
are concerns that I either share
entirely or certainly sympathize with
right so like that's not
that's not the issue the issue is
a threat to democracy and something well
the issue is largely what you said it
was it's not so much the person it's the
effect on everything he touches right he
just he has this this superpower of
deranging and destabilizing
uh almost everything he touches and
Sully in the and compromising the
Integrity of almost anyone who comes
into his orbit I mean so he looked at
these people who served you know as
Chief of Staff or you know in various
cabinet positions people had real
reputations you know for for probity and
and level-headedness uh you know whether
you share their politics or not I mean
these were real people these were not
you know some of them were goofballs but
um
uh
you know many people who who just got
totally trashed by
proximity to him and then Trashed by him
when they finally parted company with
him
um
yeah I mean there's just people bent
over backwards to accommodate his Norm
violations and it it was it was bad for
them and it was bad for our
our system and
but then but none of that discounts the
fact that
we have um
A system that really needs a proper
house cleaning yes there are bad
incentives and
um entrenched interests and yeah I'm not
a fan of the concept of of
the Deep State uh but because it you
know has been so propagandized but yes
there's there's something like that you
know that is uh not um
flexible enough to respond intelligently
to the needs of the moment right so
there's a lot of rethinking of
government and of institutions in
general that I think
we should do
but we need smart well-informed
well-intentioned people to do that job
and the well-intentioned part is
is hugely important right it's Gentlemen
Just give me someone
who
is not the most
selfish person anyone has ever heard
about in their lifetime right and what
we got with Trump was the like the
literally the one most selfish person I
think anyone could name
I mean and you and again you there's so
much known about this man that's the
thing it's like it predates his
presidency we knew this guy 30 years ago
yeah and and this and this is what to
come back to the those inflammatory
comments about Hunter Biden's laptop
the reason why I can say with confidence
that I don't care what was on his his
laptop is that there is and and that
includes any evidence of corruption on
the on the part of his father right now
there's been precious little of that
that's actually emerged so it's like
there is no as far as I can tell there's
not a big story associated with that
laptop as much as people bang on about a
few emails but
even if there were just obvious
corruption right like Joe Biden was at
this meeting and he took you know this
amount of money from this Shady guy
uh for bad reasons right
given how visible the lives of these two
men have been right given how much we
know about Joe Biden and how much we
know about Donald Trump and how they
have lived in public for almost as long
as I've been alive both of them
the the the the scale of corruption
can't possibly balance out between the
two of them right we I if if you show me
the Joe Biden has this secret life or
he's driving a Bugatti and he's living
like Andrew Tate right and he's do he's
doing all these things I didn't know
about okay then I'm gonna start getting
a sense that all right maybe this guy is
way more corrupt than I realize maybe
there is some deal in Ukraine or with
China that is just like this guy is not
who he seems he's not the public servant
he's been pretending to be he's been on
the take for decades and decades and
he's just he's as dirty as can be he's
all mobbed up and it's a nightmare
um and he can't be trusted right that's
possible
if you show me that his life is not at
all what it seems but on the assumption
that I having looked at this guy for
literally decades right and and knowing
that every journalist has looked at him
for decades just how many Affairs does
he have and just how much you know uh
how many drugs is he doing how many
houses does he have where you know what
what what is what are the obvious
conflicts of interest you know you hold
that against what we know about Trump
right and
I mean the Litany of indiscretions you
can put on Trump's side that that
testify to his personal corruption to
testify the fact that he has no ethical
compass
there's simply no comparison right so
that's why I don't care about what's on
the laptop when now if you tell me Trump
is no longer running for president in
2024 and we can put trumpism behind us
and now you're saying
listen there's a lot of stuff on that
laptop that makes Joe Biden look like a
total [__] okay I'm all ears right I
mean it was a force in 2020 it was a
force choice between
a sitting president who wouldn't commit
to a peaceful transfer of power
and a guy who's obviously too old
to be president who has a crack addicted
son who who you know who lost his laptop
and I just knew that I was going to take
Biden in spite of whatever Litany of
Horrors was going to come tumbling out
of that laptop and that might involve
sort of so the actual quote is Hunter
Biden literally could have had the
corpses of children in the basement
there's a dark humor to it right which
is I think you speak to I would not have
cared there's nothing it's Hunter Biden
it's not Joe Biden whatever the scopo
Joe Biden's corruption is it is
infinitesimally compared to the
corruption we know Trump was involved in
it's like a firefly to the sun is what
you're speaking to but let me make the
case that you're really focused on the
surface stuff
that it's possible to have corruption
that masquerades in the thing we
mentioned which is civility you commend
you can spend hundreds of billions of
dollars or trillions towards the War uh
in the Middle East for example something
that you've changed your mind on in
terms of the negative impact it has on
the world and that you know the military
industrial complex
it's everybody's very nice everybody's
very civil it's very upfront here's how
we're spending the money yeah sometimes
somehow disappears in different places
but that's the way you know war is
complicated and it's everyone is very
polite there's no uh Coke and strippers
or whatever is on the laptop
um it's very nice and polite in the
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
civilians die uh hate it just an
incredible amount of hate is created
because people lose their family members
all that kind of stuff but there's no
strippers in Coke on a laptop so yeah
but but it's not just superficial it is
when you when someone only wants wealth
and power and fame and so this is that
is their their objective function right
they're like a a robot that is
calibrated just to those variables right
and they don't care about the risks we
run on any other front they don't care
about I mean
environmental risk pandemic risk nuclear
proliferation risk none of it right they
just they're just tracking Fame and
money and and whatever can can
personally uh red down to their
self-interest along those lines and
they're not informed about the other
risks we're running really I mean in
Trump you you had a president who was
repeatedly asking his generals why
couldn't we use our nuclear weapons why
can't we have more of them why do I have
fewer nuclear weapons than JFK right as
though that were a sign of of of
anything other than progress right
um
and this is the guy who's got the the
the button right I mean he's got
somebody's following him around with a
bag waiting to take his order to to
launch right
um
that is a
it's just it's a it's a risk we should
never run one thing Trump has going for
him I think is that he's he doesn't
drink or do drugs right I although
there's you know people allege that he
does speed but
um you know let's take him in his word
he's he's uh not deranging himself with
with Pharmaceuticals at least but
um apart from diet coke uh
but there's nothing wrong just for the
record let me push back on that there's
nothing wrong with that girl yeah a very
large amount I occasionally have some
myself there's no medical there's no
scientific evidence that I observed the
negatives of you know all those studies
about aspartame and all that is um no I
don't know if I I hope I hope you're
right
um yeah I mean everything you said about
the military industrial complex is true
right and it's been we've been worrying
about that on both sides of the aisle
for a very long time I mean that's just
that phrase came from from Eisenhower
um
it's uh
I mean so much of
what ails us is a story of bad
incentives right and bad incentives are
so powerful
that they corrupt even good people right
how much more do they corrupt bad people
right like so it's like you want to at
minimum you want reasonably good people
at least non-pathological people in Us
in the system
trying to navigate against the grain of
bad incentives and better still
all of us can get together and try to
diagnose those incentives and change
them right and and and we will really
succeed when we have a system of
incentives where
the the good incentives are so strong
that even bad people are effortlessly
behaving as though they're good people
because they're so successfully
incentivized to behave that way right
that's you know so so it's it's almost
the inversion of our current situation
so yes
and you say I changed my mind about the
War uh I not quite I mean I I was never
a supporter of the war in Iraq I was
always worried that it was a distraction
from the war in Afghanistan I was a
supporter of the war in Afghanistan and
I will admit in hindsight that looks
like uh
you know at best a highly ambiguous and
painful exercise you know more likely a
Fool's errand right I was like that
would you know it did not turn out well
it's it's
it wasn't for want of trying I I don't
you know I have not done a deep dive on
on all of the failures there and maybe
all of these failures or failures in
principle I mean maybe it's just maybe
that's not the kind of thing that can be
done well by anybody whatever our
intentions
um but yeah the move to Iraq always
seemed questionable to me and um
when we knew the problem the immediate
problem at that moment you know Al Qaeda
uh
was in Afghanistan and you know and then
bouncing to Pakistan
um
anyway all you know so yes but my
my sense of the possibility of nation
building my sense of of
um
you know and so insofar as the the the
neocon
um
a spirit of of
you know responsibility and idealism
that you know America was the kind of
nation that should be functioning in
this way as as the world's cop and we've
got we have to get in there and and
untangle some of these knots by force
um uh rather often because
you know if we don't do it over there
we're gonna have to do it over here kind
of thing
um yeah some of that has definitely
changed for me in my thinking
I mean they're obviously cultural
reasons why it failed in Afghanistan and
if you can't change the culture
um it's uh
you're not going to force a change at
gunpoint in the culture or it certainly
seems that that's not going to happen
and it took us you know over 20 years to
apparently realize that that's one of
the things you realize with the war is
there's not going to be a strong signal
that things are not working you can just
keep pouring money into a thing a
military effort well also there are
signs of it working too you have all the
stories of girls now going to school
right you know the girls are getting
battery acid thrown in their faces by
religious maniacs and then we come in
there and we stop that and now girls are
getting educated and there's a and
that's all good and our intentions are
good there and I mean we're on the right
side of history there good girls should
be going to school you know Malala
yosef'sai should have the Nobel Prize
and she shouldn't have been shot in the
face by by the Taliban right
um
we know what the right answers are there
the question is what do you do when
there are enough in this particular case
religious Maniacs who are willing to die
and let their children die in defense of
crazy ideas and moral Norms that belong
in the 7th century
um and it's a problem we couldn't solve
and we couldn't solve it even though we
spent you know trillions of dollars to
solve it this reminded me of um the
thing that you and and Jack Dorsey uh
jokingly had for a while the discussion
about banning uh Donald Trump from
Twitter uh but does any of it bother you
now that Twitter files came out
that I mean this has to do with sort of
the hunter laptop Hunter byton laptop
story does it bother you that there
could be a collection of people that
make decisions about who to ban and not
and then
that could be susceptible to bias and to
ideological influence well I I think
it always will be or in the absence of
perfect AI it always will be and this
becomes relevant with AI as well yeah
because yeah some censorship and AI
happening yeah and it's an interesting
question there as well I don't think
Twitter as important as people think it
is right and and I I used to think it
was more important when I was on it and
now that I'm off of it I think it's it's
uh
I mean first let me say it's just a an
unambiguously good thing in my
experience to delete your Twitter
account right it's like it is just even
the good parts of Twitter that I miss
were bad in the aggregate in the the
degree to which it was fragmenting my
attention the degree to which my life
was getting doled out to me in
periods between those moments where I
checked Twitter right and had my
attention diverted and I was you know I
was not a a crazy Twitter addict I mean
I was a I was probably a pretty normal
user I mean I was not someone who was
tweeting multiple times a day or even
every day right I probably
I think I probably averaged
something like one tweet a day I think I
average but in reality it was like you
know there'd be like four tweets one day
and then I wouldn't tweet for you know
the better part of a week
and but I was looking
a lot because it was my news feed I was
just following you know 200 very smart
people and I just wanted to see what
they were paying attention to and they
would recommend articles and I would
read those articles and and then when I
would read an article then I would that
I would thought I should signal boost I
would tweet and so all of that seemed
good and you know like that's all
separable from all of the odious
[__] that came back at me in
response to this largely in response to
this Hunter Biden thing
um
but even the good stuff
has a downside and and it and it comes
at just this point of your phone is this
Perpetual stimulus of
um
which is intrinsically fragmenting of
time and attention and now my phone is
is much less of a presence in my life
and it's it's not that I don't check
slack or check email I mean you know I I
use it to work but
um
my sense of just what the world is in my
sense of my place in the world the sense
of where I exist as a person
has changed a lot by deleting my Twitter
account I mean I had a you know and it's
just
it's um and the things that I think I
mean we all know this phenomenon because
we say of someone that person is too
online right like what does it mean to
be too online
and where do you draw the that that
boundary you know how do you know what
constitutes being too online well
in some sense just be I think being on
on social media at all is to be too
online I mean get given what it does to
given the kinds of information it it um
signal boosts and given the um
given the impulse it Kindles in each of
us to reach out to our audience
in at in specific moments and in
specific ways right it's like
there there are lots of moments now
where I have an opinion about something
but there's nothing for me to do with
that opinion right like there's no
Twitter right so like there's lots of
things that I would have tweeted in the
last months
that are not the kind of thing I'm going
to do a podcast about I'm not going to
roll out 10 minutes on that topic on my
podcast I'm not going to take the time
to really think about it but had I been
on Twitter I would have reacted to this
thing in the news or this thing that
some somebody did right what do you do
with that thought no I just let go of it
like chocolate ice cream is the most
delicious thing yeah it's usually not
that sort of thing but it's it's just
but then you look at the kinds of
problems people create for themselves
you look at the life deranging and
reputation destroying things that people
do
and and I look at the things that that
have the analogous things that have
happened to me I mean the things that
have really bent my life around
professionally over the past you know
decade
so much of it is Twitter I mean it
honestly in my case almost a hundred
percent of it was Twitter the
controversies I would get into the
things I would think I would have to
respond to in a pot like I would release
a podcast on a certain topic I would see
some blowback on Twitter
you know it would give me the sense that
there was some signal that I really had
to respond to now that I'm off Twitter I
recognize that most of that was just
it was totally specious right it was it
was not something I had to respond to
but yet I would then do a cycle of
podcasts responding to that thing that
like to taking my foot out of my mouth
or taking someone else's foot out of my
mouth and it became this this
self-perpetuating
uh cycle which
I mean what it's you know if you're
having fun great I mean if it's if it's
if it's generative of useful information
and and engagement professionally and
and psychologically great but and and
there you know there was some of that on
Twitter I mean there were people who
I've connected with because because I
just you know one one of us dm'd the
other on Twitter and it was hard to see
how that was going to happen otherwise
but
it was largely just a machine for
manufacturing unnecessary controversy do
you think it's possible to avoid the
drug of that so now that you've achieved
the Zen state is it possible for
somebody like you to use it in a way
that doesn't pull you into the whirlpool
and so anytime there's a tax you just I
mean that's how I tried to use it yeah
but it's not the way I wanted to use it
it's not the way it it it promises
itself as as they wanted to have debate
I wanted to actually communicate with
people yeah I want I wanted to hear from
the person because
again it's like being in Afghanistan
right it's like there there are the the
Potted cases where it's obviously good
right it's like in Afghanistan the girl
who's getting an education that is just
here that's why we're here that's that's
Obviously good I have those moments on
Twitter where I'm hearing from a smart
person who's detected an error or I made
in my podcast or in a book or they've
just got some great idea about something
that I should spend time on and I would
never have heard from this person in any
other format and now I'm actually in
dialogue with them and it's fantastic
that's the promise of it to actually
talk to people and so I kept getting
lured back into that
um no the the way the same or you know
sanity preserving way of of using it is
is
just as a marketing channel you just put
your stuff out there and you don't look
at what's coming back at you
um and that's you know for you know I'm
on other social media platforms
that I don't even touch I mean my team
put post stuff on Facebook and on
Instagram I never even see what's on
there so you don't think it's possible
to see something
and not let it affect your mind no
that's definitely possible but the
question is and I did that for vast
stretches of time right and but then
the the promise of the platform
is dialogue and feedback right so like
so why did my if I know
for whatever reason I'm gonna see like
99 to one awful feedback you know bad
faith feedback malicious feedback some
of it's probably even Bots and I'm not
even aware of who's a person who's a bot
right but I'm just going to stare into
this fun house mirror of
acrimony and dishonesty
um that is going to I mean the the
reason why I got off is
not because I couldn't recalibrate and
and find Equanimity again with all the
the the nastiness that was coming back
at me and not that I couldn't ignore it
for vast rushes of time but
I could see that I kept coming back to
it
hoping that it would be something that I
could use a real tool for communication
and I was noticing
that it was insidiously changing
the way I felt about people both people
I know and people I don't know right
like people I you know mutual friends of
ours who are behaving in certain ways on
Twitter which just seem insane to me uh
and then that became a signal I felt
like I had to take into account somehow
right you're seeing people at their
worst you're both friends and strangers
um and I I felt that it was as much as I
could sort of try to recalibrate for it
I felt that I was losing touch with what
was real information because people are
performing people are faking people are
not who themselves or they're you've
seen people at their worst and so I felt
like all right what's at was being
advertised to me
here on a not just a daily basis I you
know a hourly basis or you know an
increment sometimes of you know multiple
times an hour I mean I probably check
Twitter
you know at minimum 10 times a day and
maybe I was checking it a hundred times
a day on some days right where things
were really active and I was really
engaged with something
um
what was being delivered into my brain
there was a was
subtly false information about how
dishonest
and
um
you know just generally unethical
totally normal people are capable of
being right it was like it was it is a
fun house mirror it was it was I was
seeing the most grotesque versions of
people who I know right people who I
know I could sit down and at dinner with
and they would never behave this way and
yet they were they were coming at me on
Twitter and I mean it's it's essentially
turning Ordinary People into sociopaths
right it's like people are just
um you know it's and their analogies
that many of us have made it's like it's
like one analogy is road rage right like
people behave in the confines of a car
in ways that they never would if they
didn't have this metal box around them
you know and moving at speed and it's
it's you know all that becomes quite
hilarious and and um
you know obviously dysfunctional when
they're actually have to stop at the
light next to the person they just
flipped off and they realized they
didn't realize they didn't understand
that the person coming out of that car
next to them with cauliflower ear is
someone who they never would have you
know rolled their eyes at in public
because they would have taken one look
at this person realized this this is the
last person you want to fight with
that's one of the heartbreaking things
is to see
see people who I know who I admire who I
know are friends
be everything from snarky to downright
yeah uh mean uh
derisive towards each other it doesn't
make any sense like this this is the
only place where I've seen people I
really admire who have had a calm head
about most things like really be shitty
to other people it's probably the only
place I've seen that and I don't I don't
I tend I choose to maybe believe that
that's not really them there's something
about the system
um like if you go paintballing if you
Jordan Peterson and uh you're gonna
shoot your friends yeah yeah you're
gonna shoot your friends but you kind of
accept that that's kind of what you're
doing in this little game that you're
playing but it's sometimes hard to
remind yourself of that well and I I
think I was guilty of that definitely
um
foreign
you know I don't think there's nothing I
I don't think I ever did anything that I
really feel bad about but yeah it was
always pushing me to the edge of
snidness somehow and
um it's just not healthy it's not it's
not uh
I'm so so the so the reason why I
deleted my Twitter account in the end
was that it was obviously making me a
worse person
and and so
and yeah is there some way to be on
there where he's not making you a worse
person I I'm sure there is but it's
given the nature of the platform and
given what was coming back at me on it
the way to do that is just to basically
use it as a one-way channel of of
communication just just marketing and
it's like here here's what I what I'm
paying attention to look at it if you
want to and just push it out and then
you don't you don't look at what's
coming back at you I put out a call for
questions on Twitter and then actually
quite surprising there's a lot of good I
mean they're they're like even if
they're critical they're like being
thoughtful which is nice I used it that
way too and that was what kept me hooked
but then there's also uh touch balls 69
wrote a question ask what I can't
imagine this part of it but one way to
solve this is yeah you know we've got to
get rid of anonymity for this it's like
let me ask the question ask Sam why he
sucks was the question well
yeah one reason why I sucked was Twitter
that was uh and I I've sensed solved
that problem so I mean touch ball 69 69
yeah 69 should be happy that I I suck a
little bit less now that I'm off Twitter
I mean I don't have to hear from touch
bowls 69 on the regular the fact that
you have to uh see that
it probably can have a negative effect
just even in moderation just to see that
there is like for me the negative effect
is um slightly losing faith
in the underlying kindness of humanity
yeah that was for me yeah you can also
just reason your way out of it saying
that this is an enemy and this is kind
of fun and it's kind of just the the
[__] show of Twitter it's okay but it
does mentally affect you a little bit
like I don't read too much into that
kind of comment it's like it's just
that's just
uh trolling and it's you know I I get
what's I I get I understand the fun the
person is having on the other side of
that it's like do you though I do well I
do I don't I mean I don't behave that
way but I do and for all I know that
person could be you know 16 years old
right so it's like it could be also an
all-time for Elon I don't know
um
but you love each other okay so the do
you think so speaking of which now that
Elon have has taken over Twitter
uh is there something that he could do
to make this platform better
this Twitter and just social media in
general but because of the aggressive
nature of his Innovation that he's
pushing is there any way to make Twitter
a pleasant place for Sam Harris
I think I'm agnostic as to whether or
not he or anyone could make a social
media platform that really was healthy
so you were just observing yourself week
by week seeing the effect that's on your
mind and on how much you're actually
learning and growing as a person and it
was negative yeah and I also seen the
negativity in other people's lives I
mean it's obvious I mean he's not gonna
he's not gonna admit it but I think it's
obviously negative for Elon right it's
just not it's
uh and that was one of the things that
you know he you know when I was looking
into the fun house mirror I was also
seeing that the fun house mirror on his
side of Twitter and it was just even
more exaggerated it's like when I when I
was asking myself why is he spending his
time this way
I then reflected on why why you know why
was I spending my time this way to a
lesser degree right and at a lesser
scale and Adolescent risk frankly right
and so
um
and it was just so it's not just Twitter
it is this isn't part an internet
phenomenon it's like the the whole
Hunter Biden mess that you you um
explored that was based I mean it was on
I was on somebody's podcast but that was
based on a clip taken from that podcast
which was highly misleading as to the
the general shape of my remarks on that
podcast
even you know I I had to then do my own
podcast uh untangling all of that and
admitting that even even in the full
context I was not speaking especially
well and didn't say exactly what I
thought in a way that was would have
been recognizable to anyone you know
even someone with
not functioning by a uh a spirit of
Charity but but the clip was quite
distinct from the podcast itself the
reality is is that we're living in an
environment now where people are so lazy
and there's their attention is so
fragmented
that they they only have time for Clips
99 of people will see a clip and we'll
assume
there's no relevant contacts I need to
understand what happened in that clip
right and
obviously the people who make those
clips know that right and they're doing
that doing it quite maliciously and in
this case the person who made that clip
and subsequent clips of other podcasts
was quite maliciously trying to engineer
you know some reputational immolation
for me
um
and
being signal boosted by Elon and other
prominent people who can't take the time
to watch anything other than a clip even
when it's their friend or someone who's
ostensibly their friend in that clip
right so it's a total failure an
understandable failure of ethics
that everyone is so short on time and
they're so [__] lazy that the and and
that we now have these contacts in which
we react so quickly to things right like
Twitter is inviting an instantaneous
reaction to this clip that
it's um
it's just too tempting to just say
something and not know what you're even
commenting on and most of most of the
people who saw that clip
don't understand
what I what I actually think about any
of these issues and the irony is people
are going to find clips from this
conversation that are just as misleading
and they're going to export those and
then people are going to be dunking on
those clips and you know we're all
living and dying by clips now and it's
um
it's dysfunctional so yeah I think it's
possible to create a platform I think we
will keep living on Clips but you know
when I saw that clip of you talking
about children and so on just knowing
that you have a sense of humor you just
went to a dark place in terms of humor
right so like I didn't even bother and
then I knew that the way Clips work is
that people will use it for virality's
sake but the giving giving a person
benefit of the doubt that's not even the
right term it's not like I was it was
really like interpreting it
in the context
the truth is you even need like I even
give
Trump the benefit of the doubt when I
see a clip of trump I mean so because
there are famous clips of trump that are
very misleading as to what he was saying
in context and I've been honest about
that like the whole you know there were
good people on both sides Scandal around
the chart his remarks after
Charlottesville
the clip that got exported and got
promoted by everyone uh you know left of
center from Biden on down you know the
New York Times CNN there's nobody that
I'm aware of
who has
honestly uh you know apologized for what
they did with that clip that he did not
say what he seemed to be saying In that
clip about the Nazis at Charlottesville
right and I've always been very clear
about that uh so it's just you know I I
even even people who I think
should be marginalized and people who
who
um
who should be defenestrated because they
really are terrible people who are doing
dangerous things and for bad reasons
I think we should be honest about what
they actually meant in context right and
and this this goes to
anyone else we might talk about you know
who who's more where the where the case
is much more confusing but yeah so
everyone's care it's just so direct and
then I'm sure we're gonna get to AI but
you know the prospect of being able to
manufacture Clips with AI and deep fakes
and that where it's going to be hard for
most people most of the time to even
figure out that the the whether they're
in the presence of something real
um you know forget about being divorced
from Context there was no context uh
I mean that is that's an a
misinformation apocalypse that is we are
right on the cusp of and you know it's
it's terrifying well it could be just a
new world like where Alice going to
Wonderland or humor is the only thing we
have and that will save us maybe in the
end Trump's approach to social media was
the right one after all nothing is true
and everything's absurd
yeah but we can't live that way people
function on the basis of what they
assume is true right they think it will
have functioned what to do anything it's
like I mean you have to you have to know
what you think is going to happen or you
have to at least give a probabilistic
waiting over the future otherwise you're
you're going to be incapacitated by
you're not getting like people want
certain things and they have to have a
rational plan to get those desires
gratified and they don't want to die
they don't want their kids to die you
tell them that there's a comet hurtling
toward Earth and they should get outside
and look up right they're going to do it
and if it turns out it's misinformation
you know it's it's uh
it's going to matter because it comes
down to like what medicines do you give
your children right like we're going to
be manufacturing fake Journal articles I
mean this is I'm sure someone's using
chat GPT for for this you know as we
speak and
if it's not credible if it's not
persuasive now to most people
I mean honestly I don't think we're
gonna it's this I'll be amazed if it's a
year before we can actually create
Journal articles that would take you
know a a PhD to debunk
uh that are completely fake
um and they're people who are
celebrating this kind of
um
you know coming cataclysm but I just
it's just they're the people who
don't have anything to lose who are
celebrating it or just or so confused or
they just don't even know what's at
stake and then they're the people who
have met the few people
who we could count on a few hands who
have managed to insulate themselves or
at least imagine they've insulated
insulated themselves from the downside
here enough
that they're not implicated in the great
unraveling we are witnessing or could
could witness the shaking up of what is
true uh so actually that returns us to
experts do you think experts can save us
is there such thing as expertise and
experts in something how do you know if
you've achieved it I think it's it's
important to acknowledge up front that
this there's something paradoxical about
how we relate to to Authority especially
within science
um and I don't think a paradox is going
away and it's just it doesn't have to be
confusing it's just and it's not it's
not truly a paradox it's just like there
are different moments in time
so
it is true to say
that
within science or within a within
rationality generally I mean just
whenever you're making having a
fact-based discussion about anything
it is true to say that the truth or
falsity of a statement
does not even slightly depend on the
credentials of the person making the
statement right so it doesn't matter if
you're a Nobel Laureate you can be wrong
right the thing you could either the
last sentence you spoke could be total
[__] right
and it's also possible for someone who's
deeply uninformed to be right about
something or in order to be right for
the wrong reasons right or someone just
gets lucky or someone or or and they're
they're middling cases where you have
like a a backyard astronomer who's got
no credentials but he just loves
astronomy and he's got a telescope and
it's he's spends a lot of time looking
at the nice guy
and he discovers a comet that no one
else has seen you know not even
the professional expert astronomers
um
my God I think that happens less and
less now but but some version of that
keeps happening and it may always keep
happening in every area of expertise
right
um
so
it's true that truth is orthogonal to
the reputational concerns we have among
Apes who are talking about the truth
um but it is also true that most of the
time
real experts are much more reliable than
frauds or people who are not experts
right you know so and expertise really
is a thing right and when it's you know
when you're flying an airplane in a in a
storm
you don't want just randos come into the
cockpit saying listen I've got a new
idea about how to you know how we should
tweak these controls right you want
someone who's a trained pilot and and
that training gave them something right
it gave them a set of competences and
intuitions and they they know what all
those dials and switches do right and I
don't right I shouldn't be flying that
plane
um
and so when things really matter
you know and put in this at 30 000 feet
in a storm sharpens this up
we want real experts to be in charge
right and
we are at 30 000 feet a lot of the time
on a lot of issues right and whether
they're public health issues whether
it's issue whether it's a geopolitical
emergency like Ukraine
climate change
I mean just pick your pick your topic
um
there are real problems
and the clock is rather often ticking
and their Solutions are non-obvious
right and and so expertise is a thing
and deferring to experts much of the
time
makes a lot of sense it's at minimum it
it
prevents
you know spectacular errors of
incompetence and and uh
just uh you know foolhardiness but it
even in in the case of some where you're
talking about someone I mean people like
ourselves who are like we're well
educated we we're not the worst possible
candidates for you know the
dunning-kruger effect when we're going
into a new area where we're not experts
we're fairly alert to the possibility
that we don't you know it's not as
simple as things seem at first and we
don't you know we don't know how our
tools translate to this new area we can
be fairly circumspect but we're also
because we're well educated
we can work and we're pretty quick
studies we can learn a lot of things
pretty fast and we can begin to play a
language game that sounds fairly expert
right and
in that case
the the invitation to do your own
research right is in once when times are
good
I view as an invitation to waste your
time pointlessly right when times are
good now the truth is times are not all
that good right and we have the
the ongoing public display of failures
of expertise we have experts who are
obviously corrupted by bad incentives
we've got experts who you know
perversely won't admit they were wrong
when they in fact you know are
demonstrated to be wrong we've got
institutions that have been captured by
political ideology that's not truth
tracking and this this whole woke
um
uh encroachment into really every place
you know whether it's universities or
science journals or government or I mean
it's just like that is that has been
genuinely deranging
um
so there's a lot going on that where
experts and and the Very concept of
expertise has seemed to discredit itself
but the reality is that there is a
massive difference when anything matters
when there's anything to know about
anything there is a massive difference
most of the time between someone who has
really done the work to understand that
domain and someone who hasn't and
if I get sick or someone close to me
gets sick
you know I I have a PhD in Neuroscience
right so I can read a medical journal
article and understand a lot of it right
and I you know so I'm just fairly
conversant with you know medical
terminology
and I understand his methods and I I'm
alert to the difference because I've you
know because in Neuroscience I've spent
hours and hours in journal clubs you
know diagnosing you know the different
and analyzing the difference between
good and bad studies
I'm I'm alert to the difference between
good and bad studies and in medical
journals right and I understand that bad
studies can get published and you know
Etc
uh and and experiments can be poorly
designed
I'm alert to all of those things but
when I get sick or when someone close to
me gets sick I don't pretend to be a
doctor right I've got no clinical
experience I don't go down the rabbit
hole on Google for days at a stretch
trying to become a doctor much less a
specialist in the domain of problem that
has been visited upon me or my family
right so if someone close to me gets
cancer I don't pretend to be an
oncologist I don't go out and start I
don't start reading you know in journals
of oncology and try to really get up to
speed as an oncologist because it's it's
not it's
one is a one is a bad and potential and
very likely misleading
use of my time right and it and it's
if I decide if I had if I had a lot of
Runway if I decided okay it's really
important for me to know everything I
can at this point I want to I know
someone's gonna get cancer
I may not go back to school and become
an oncologist but what I want to do is I
want to know everything I can know about
cancer right so I'm going to take the
next four years and spend most of my
time on cancer okay I could do that
right I still think that's a waste of my
time uh I still think at the end of even
at the end of those four years I'm not
going to be the best person to to form
intuitions about what to do in the face
of the next cancer that I have to
confront
um
I'm still going to want a better
oncologist than I've become to tell me
what he or she would do if they were in
my shoes or in the shoes of you know my
family member I'm gonna you know I'm
what I'm what I'm not Advocate I'm not
advocating a
a blind trust and Authority like if you
get cancer
and you're talking to one oncologist and
they're recommending some course of
treatment by all means get a second
opinion get a third opinion right but it
matters that those opinions are coming
from real experts and not from you know
Robert Kennedy Jr you know who's telling
you that you know you got it because you
got a you know a vaccine right it's like
it's it's just it it there's we're
swimming in a sea of misinformation
where you've got people
who are moving the opinions of millions
of others
who sh who should not have an opinion on
these topics like there's no there is no
scenario in which you should be getting
your opinion about vaccine safety or or
climate change or
uh the war in Ukraine or anything else
that we might want to talk about from
Candace Owens right it's just like it
like like she she's not a relevant
expert on any of those topics and what's
more she doesn't seem to care right and
and she's living in a culture that has
that has
Amplified that not caring into a
business model and an effective business
model right so it's just it's um and
then there's something very trumpy and
about all that or like that's that's the
pro the problem is is the culture it's
not these specific individuals
um so so the Paradox here is that
expertise is a real thing
and we defer to it a lot as a as a
labor-saving device as just as and just
based on the the
the the reality that it's very hard to
be a polymath right and specialization
is a thing right and so there are people
who specialize in a very narrow topic
they know more about that topic than the
next guy no matter how smart that that
guy or gal is uh
and and that those differences matter
but it's also true
that when you're talking about facts
sometimes
the the the the best experts are wrong
the scientific consensus is wrong you
get a a sea change in the thinking of a
whole field because one person who's an
outlier for whatever reason decides okay
I'm uh you know I'm gonna prove this
point and they prove it right so
somebody like uh
the Doctor Who uh believed that that
stomach ulcers were not due to stress
but were due to to um H pylori
infections right so he just drank a vial
of H pylori bacteria and and prove that
and quickly got an ulcer and convinced
the field that that at minimum H pylori
was involved in in that process okay so
yes everyone was wrong that doesn't
disprove the reality of expertise it
doesn't disprove the utility of relying
on Experts most of the time especially
in an emergency especially when the
clock is ticking especially when you're
you know you're in this particular
cockpit and you only have one chance to
land this plane right you want the real
pilot uh at the controls but there's
just a few things to say
so one you mentioned this example with
cancer and doing your own research there
there are several things that are
different about
our particular time in history one doing
your own research has become more and
more effective because you can read the
internet made information a lot more
accessible so you can read a lot of
different meta-analyzes you can read
blog posts that
described you exactly the flaws and the
different papers they make up the meta
meta-analyzes they and you can read a
lot of those blog posts that are
conflicting with each other and you can
take that information in and in a short
amount of time you can start to make
um
good faith interpretations for example I
don't know I don't want to overstate
things but
um if you suffer from depression for
example
then there you could go to an expert and
a doctor that prescribes you some
medication
but you could also challenge some of
those ideas and seeing like what are the
different medications what are the
different side effects what are the
different solutions to depression all
that kind of stuff and I think
depression is just a really difficult
problem that's very
um I don't want to Again State incorrect
things but I think it's
um there's a lot of variability of what
depression really means so it being
introspective about the type of
depression you have and the different
possible solutions you have just doing
your own research as a first step before
approaching a doctor or as you have
multiple opinions could be very
beneficial in that case
now that's depression that's something
that's been studied for a very long time
with a new pandemic that's affecting
everybody
it's uh you know with the airplane
equated to like 9 11 or something like
the new emergency just happened and
everybody every expert in the world is
publishing on it and talking about it so
doing your own research there could be
exceptionally effective in asking
questions and then there's a difference
between experts virologists and it's
actually a good question who is exactly
the expert in a pandemic yeah but
there's the actual experts doing the
research and Publishing stuff
and then there's the communicators of
that expertise
and the question is uh if the
communicators are flawed
to to a degree we're doing your own
research is actually the more effective
way to figure out policies and solutions
because you're not competing with
experts you're competing with the
communicators of expertise that could be
who CDC in the case of the pandemic or
politicians or political type of science
figures like Anthony fauci there's a
question there
of
the effectiveness of doing your research
your own research in that context
and the competing
forces there incentives that you've
mentioned is you can be become quite
popular by being contrarian
by saying everybody's lying to you all
the authorities aligned to all the
institutions aligned to you so those are
the waters you're swimming in but I
think doing your own research in that
kind of context could be quite effective
let me be clear I'm not saying
you shouldn't do any research right I'm
not saying that you shouldn't be
informed about an issue I'm not saying
you shouldn't read articles on on
whatever the topic is and yeah yes if I
got cancer or someone close to me got
cancer I I I probably would read more
about cancer than I've read thus far
about cancer and I've read some
um
so I'm not I'm not making a virtue of
ignorance
and a blind obedience to Authority and I
again I recognize that that authorities
can discredit themselves or they can be
wrong
uh they can be wrong even when they had
when there's no discredit there's just
there's a lot we don't understand about
the the nature of the world
um
but still this this vast Gulf between
truly informed opinion and [__]
exists it always exists and
um and conspiracy thinking is
rather often you know most of the time
the species of [__] but it's not
always wrong right there are real
conspiracies and there there really are
just awful
Corruptions of you know but born of bad
incentives within our you know our
scientific processes within institutions
and again we've mentioned a lot of these
things in passing but you know what what
woke political ideology did to
Scientific communication during the
pandemic was awful and it was really
corrosive of public trust especially on
the on the right
um for understandable reasons and it was
just it was crazy some of the things
that were being said and still is
and these cases are all different so you
take depression but we just don't know
enough about depression for you know
anyone to be that confident about
anything right and there are many
different modalities in which to
interact with it as a problem right so
there's Pharmaceuticals have whatever
promise they have but there's there's
certainly reason to be concerned that
they don't work well for everybody and
and
uh yeah I mean that's it's obvious they
don't work well for everybody but they
do work for some people
um
but again depression is a multifactorial
problem and they're they're different
levels at which to to influence it and
they're you know the things like
meditation they're things like just life
changes and
and uh
you know one of the perverse things
about depression is that when you're
depressed all of the things that would
be good for you to do or precisely
things you don't want to do you don't
have any energy to socialize you don't
want to get things done you don't want
to exercise you don't and
um all of those things if you've got
those up and running they do make you
feel better in you know in the aggregate
but um the reality is that they're you
know there are clinical level
depressions that are so bad that it's
just we just don't have good tools for
them and it's not enough to tell there's
no life change someone's gonna gonna
Embrace that it's going to be an obvious
remedy for that
um
the pan I mean pandemics are are
obviously a complicated problem but I I
would consider it much simpler than
depression in terms of
you know what's on the menu to be this
chosen among the various choices just
less multifactorial the logic by which
you would make those choices yeah so
it's like we have a virus we have a new
virus
it's some version of bad you know it's
human transmissible
we're still catching up we're catching
up to every aspect of we don't know how
it spreads we don't know how how
effective masks are at a certain point
we knew it was respiratory but we knew
and whether it's spread by fomites like
all we were confused about a lot of
things and was still confused it's been
a moving Target this whole time and it's
been changing this whole time and our
responses to it have been
you know we we ramped up the vaccines as
quickly as we as we could but you know
too quick for some not as not quick
enough for others we could have done
human challenge trials and got them out
more quickly with with better data
um and I think that's something we
should probably look at in the future
because you know that you know to my eye
that would make ethical sense to do to
do challenge trials
um
but
and and so much of my concern about
covid I mean many people are confused
about my concern about covet my concern
about covet has
for much of the time not been narrowly
focused on covet itself how dangerous I
perceive covid to be as a as a illness
um
it has been for the longest time
even more concerned about our ability to
respond to a truly scary pathogen next
time like what I I for you know outside
those initial months you know if give me
the the first six months to be
quite worried about covid and and the
unraveling of society but in a supply of
toilet paper you want to secure a steady
supply of toilet paper but beyond that
initial period
when we had a sense of what we were
dealing with and we had every hope that
the vaccines are actually going to work
and we're getting and we knew we were
getting those vaccines in short order
right beyond that and and we had and and
we knew just how dangerous the illness
was and how dangerous it wasn't
um
for years now I've just been worrying
about this as a failed dress rehearsal
for something much worse right I think
what we proved to ourselves at this
moment in history is that
we have built informational tools that
we do not know how to use to and we have
made ourselves we've basically enrolled
all of human society into a
psychological experiment
that is
deranging us and making it
virtually impossible to solve
coordination problems that we absolutely
have to solve next time when things are
worse do you understand who's at fault
for the way this unraveled
the way we didn't seem to have uh
the distrust institutions and the
institution of science that grew like
seemingly exponentially or got revealed
through this process who is a fault here
and what's to fix so much blame to go
around but so much of it is not a matter
of
bad people conspiring to do bad things
it's a matter of
uh incompetence and misaligned
incentives and just just ordinary you
know believe there's plain vanilla
dysfunction but my problem was that
people like you people like Brett
Weinstein people like that I look to for
reasonable difficult conversations on
difficult topics
have a little bit lost their mind became
emotional and dogmatic in style of
conversation perhaps not in the depth of
actual ideas but there I you know I
tweet something of that nature and not
about you but just it feels like the
pandemic
made people really more emotional than
before and then Kimball musk responded I
think something I think you probably
would agree with maybe not I think it
was the combo of trump and the pandemic
Trump triggered the far left to be way
more active than they could have been
without him and then the pandemic handed
big government Nanny State Lefty is a
huge platform on a silver platter a
one-two punch and here we are well I
would agree with some of that I'm not
sure how much to read into the nanny
State uh concept but but yet like
basically got people on the far left
really activated yeah and then gave
control to I don't know if you say Nanny
state but just control the government
that one executed poorly has created a
complete distrust in government my fear
is that there was going to be that
complete distrust anyway given the
nature of the information space given
the level of conspiracy thinking given
the gaming of
of the these tools by an anti-vaxx cult
I mean there really is an anti-vaxx cult
that that just ramped up its its energy
during this moment
um but it's a small one it's not to say
that everything every concern about
vaccines is a species of it was born of
misinformation or born of this cult but
there is a cult that is just you know
and you know
and the core of trumpism is a cult I
mean a q Anon is a cult
um and so there's a lot of lying and
there's a lot of confusion
uh you know there there are
it's almost impossible to exaggerate how
confused some people are and how and how
fully their their lives are organized
around that confusion I mean there are
people who think that the world's being
run by pedophile cannibals and that you
know Tom Hanks and Oprah Winfrey and
Michelle Obama are among those cannibals
I mean like they're
adjacent to the pure crazy there's the
semi-crazy and adjacent to the
semi-crazy there's the grifting
opportunist [__] and and the the the
the the layers of
of bad faith are you know hard to fully
uh diagnose but the problem is
all of this is getting signal boosted by
a a an outrage machine that is
preferentially spreading misinformation
it has a business model that is is
guaranteed that is is preferentially
sharing misinformation okay actually
it's just a small tangent yeah how do
you defend yourself against the claim
that you're a pedophile accountable
it's difficulty here's the case I would
make because I don't think you can use
reason I think you have to use empathy
you have to understand but what like
part of it I mean I I find it very
difficult to believe that anyone
believes these things I mean I think
that there's and there's I'm sure
there's some number of people
who are just pretending to believe these
things because it's just again this is
sort of like the fortunification of
everything it's just it's just a there's
a goo it's just Pepe the Frog right like
none of this is what it seems they're
not signaling an alliance with white
supremacy or neo-nazism but they're not
not doing it like they just don't
[__] care it's just cynicism
overflowing its banks right it's just
fun to to wind up the normies right like
look at all the normies who don't
understand that a green frog is just a
green frog even when it isn't just a
green frog right it's like they're just
it's just gumming up everyone's
cognitive bandwidth with [__] right
I get that that's fun if you're a
teenager and you just want to vandalize
our our new sphere but
at a certain point you we have to
recognize that real questions of human
welfare are in play right there's like
they're really there is this their Wars
getting fought or not fought and there's
a pandemic raging and
there's medicine to take or not take but
I mean to come back to this issue of
covid
I don't think my I don't think I got so
out of balance around covid I think
people are quite confused about what I
was concerned about I mean like there
was a yes there was a period where
I was crazy because anyone who has taken
it seriously was crazy because they had
no idea what was going on and so it's
like yes I was wiping down packages with
with alcohol wipes right because
people thought it was tremendous
transmissible by touch right that so and
then when we realized that was no longer
the case I stopped doing that but so
there again it was a moving Target and a
lot of things we did in hindsight around
masking and school closures
looked fairly dysfunctional right but
it's unnecessary I think the criticism
that people would
uh would say about your uh talking about
covet and maybe you can correct me but
you were skeptical or you were against
skepticism of the safety and efficacy of
the vaccine
so people who get nervous about
the vaccine but don't fall into the
usual anti-vaxx Camp which I think there
was a significant yeah enough number
they're asking they're getting nervous I
mean I especially after the warn of
Afghanistan and rock I too was nervous
about anything where a lot of money
could be made hmm and you start you just
see how the people who are greedy who
come they come to the surface all of a
sudden and a lot of them that run
institutions actually really good human
beings and I know a lot of them but it's
hard to know
how those two combine together when
there's hundreds of billions trillions
of dollars to be made and so that
skepticism I I guess you this the sense
was that you weren't open enough to the
skepticism I understand that people have
that sense I'll tell you how I thought
about it and think about it one again it
was a moving Target so there was a point
in the timeline where
it was totally rational to expect that
the vaccines
were were both working but both they
were
they were reasonably safe and that and
that covid was reasonably dangerous and
that the trade-off for basically
everyone was it was rational to get
vaccinated given how many given the
level of testing and how many people had
been vaccinated before you given what we
were seeing with covid right
um that that was a forced choice you're
either gonna you're eventually going to
get coveted and the question is do you
want to be vaccinated when you do right
there was a period where that Force
choice where it was just obviously
reasonable to get vaccinated
in especially because there was every
reason to expect that while it wasn't a
perfectly sterilizing vaccine it was
going to knock down transmission a lot
and that matters and so it wasn't just a
personal choice you were actually being
a good citizen when you decided to run
whatever risk you you were going to run
to get vaccinated because there are
people in our society who can't actually
can't get vaccinated I mean I know
people who can't take any vaccines
they're so they're so allergic to I mean
they they in their own person seem to
justify all of the fears of the
anti-vaxx cult I mean it's like they're
the kind of person who Robert Kennedy Jr
can point to and say see vaccines are
will [__] kill you right because
because of the experience and they and
were still they I know people who have
kids who fit that description right so
um we should all feel a civic
responsibility to be vaccinated against
egregiously awful and transmissible
diseases for which we have relatively
safe vaccines
to keep those sorts of people safe and
there was a period of time when it was
thought that the vaccine could stop
transmission yes and so again all of
this is it has begun to shift
um I don't think it has shifted as much
as Brett Weinstein thinks it's shifted
but yes there are safety concerns around
the MRNA vaccines
especially for young men right as far as
I know that's the that's the purview of
the of of actual heightened concern
um but also
there's there's now a lot of natural
immunity out there a lot of basically
everyone who was going to get vaccinated
has gotten vaccinated the virus has
evolved to the point in in in this
context where
it seems less uh dangerous you know
again I don't I I I'm going more on on
the Siemens than on on Research that
I've done it at this point but I'm
certainly less worried about getting
covet I've had it once I've been
vaccinated I feel like it's like so you
ask me now how do I feel about getting
the next booster
I don't know that I'm going to get the
next booster right so so I I was
somebody who was waiting in line at four
in the morning you know hoping to get
get a some overflow vaccine when it was
first available
and I that was at that point given what
we knew
or given what I thought I knew based on
the best sources I could consult and
based on
you know based on anecdotes that were
too Vivid to ignore you know both data
and and personal experience
um
it was totally rational for me to to
want to get that vaccine as as soon as I
could
and now I think it's totally rational
for me to to do a a different kind of
cost benefit analysis and wonder listen
do I really need to get a booster right
you know like how many of the how many
of these boosters am I going to get for
the rest of my life really and how safe
is the MRNA vaccine for a man of my age
right and do I need to be worried about
myocarditis for you know
all of that is completely rational to
talk about now
my concern is that
at every point along the way
I was the wrong person and and Brett
Weinstein was the wrong person and
there's many other people I could add to
this list to have strong opinions about
any of this stuff I just disagree with
that I think
yes in theory I agree 100 but I feel
like experts failed at communicating not
at doing they did I I and I just feel
like you and Brett Weinstein actually
have the tools with the internet given
the engine you have in your brain of
thinking for months at a time deeply
about the problems that face our world
that you actually have the tools to do
pretty good thinking here it's the
problem I have with that but there would
be deference to experts and pseudo
experts behind all of that well the
papers you would stand on the shoulders
of giants but you can surf those
shoulders better than the Giants
themselves but I knew we were going to
disagree about that like I I I saw his
podcast where he brought on these
experts who had many of them had the
right credentials but for a variety of
reasons they didn't pass the smell test
for Me Maybe One larger problem this
goes back to the the problem of of how
we rely on Authority in science is that
you can always find a PhD or an MD
to to Champion any crackpot idea right
you could I mean it is amazing but you
could find phds and MDS who would sit up
there in front of Congress and say that
they thought smoking was not addictive
you know or that it was not harmful to
you know there was no direct link
between smoking and lung cancer you
could always find those people and you
could end so but you know some of the
people Brett found were people who had
obvious tells to my point of view to my
eye I mean and I saw them on some of the
same people were on Rogan's podcast
right and
um
and it's hard because if a person does
have the right credentials and they're
not and they're not saying something
floridally mistaken and we're talking
about something where
it's they're genuine unknowns right like
how how much do we know about the safety
of these vaccines right it's it's at
that point not a whole hell of a lot I
mean we have no long-term data on mRNA
vaccines
but to confidently say that millions of
people are going to die because of these
vaccines and to confidently say that
Ivermectin is a Panacea right Ivermectin
is the thing that prevents covet right
there was no good reason to say either
of those things at that moment and
that's and then and so given that that's
where Brett was
I felt like there was there was just no
there was nothing to debate we were both
the wrong people to get be getting into
the Weeds on this we're both going to
defer to our
chosen experts his experts look like
crackpots to me and
um
or at least the ones who are most
vociferous on those most on those
edgiest points it seemed most and your
experts seem like what is the term Mass
hysteria I forgot that well it's no but
it's like it's like with you know
climate science I mean this this old uh
it's received as a Canard for for in
half of our society now but the claim
that 97 of climate scientists agree that
human cause climate change is a thing
right so do you go with the 97 most of
the time or do you go with the three
percent most of the time it's obvious
you go with the 97 most of the time for
anything that matters it's not to say
that the three percent are always wrong
again the the there are things get
overturned and yes
as you say I've spent much more time
worrying about this on my podcast than
I've spent worrying about covet are
institutions have lost Trust
for good reason right and and it's it
it's an open question whether
we can actually get things done with
this level of transparency and and
pseudo-transparency given our
information ecosystems like can we fight
a war
really fight a war that we may have to
fight like the next Nazis can we fight
that war when everyone with an iPhone is
showing just how awful it is that that
little girls get blown up when we drop
our bombs right it's like could we could
we as a society do what we might have to
do
to get actually get necessary things
done when we're living in this this
panopticon of just you know everyone's a
journalist right everyone's a scientist
Everyone's an expert everyone's got
direct contact with the facts or or some
or a semblance of the facts I don't know
I think yes and I think voices like
yours are exceptionally important and I
think there's certain signals you send
in your ability to steal me on the other
side in your empathy essentially
so that's the fight that's the mechanism
by which you resist uh
the dogmatism of these this binary
thinking and then if you become a
trusted person that's able to consider
the other side then people will listen
to you as as the aggregators the
communicator of expertise because the
virologists haven't been able to be good
communicators I still to this day don't
really know
what is the what am I supposed to think
about the
um safety and efficacy of the vaccines
today as it stands today right what are
we supposed to think what are we
supposed to think about testing what are
we supposed to think about the
effectiveness of masks or lockdowns
where's the great communicators on this
topic that consider all the other
conspiracy theories all the other all
the communication that's out there
and actually aggregating it together and
be able to say this is actually what's
most likely the truth and also some of
that has to do with humility
epistemic humility knowing that you
can't really know for sure
just like with depression you can't
really know for sure yeah where is the
I'm not seeing those Communications
being effectively done even still today
well I mean the jury is still out on
some of it and again it's a moving
Target and and some of it I mean it's
complicated some of it's a
self-fulfilling
uh Dynamic where like so like lockdowns
in theory lockdowns a lockdown would
work
if we could only do it but we can't
really do it and there's a lot of people
who won't do it because they're
convinced that it's this is the
totalitarian boot you know I'm finally
on the neck of the of of of
the good people who um
uh
are always having their interests
introduced by the elites right so like
this is if you have enough people who
think the lockdown for any reason in the
face of any conceivable illness right is
just code for the new world order coming
to [__] you over and take your guns
right okay you have a society that is
now immune to reason right because
they're they're absolutely certain
pathogens that we should lock down for
next time right and and and it was
completely rational in the beginning of
this thing to lock down given to attempt
to lock down we never really locked down
to attempt some semblance of lockdown
just to quote bend the curve to spare
our health care System
given what we were seeing happen in
Italy right like that moment was it was
not hard to navigate at least in in my
view it was obvious at the time in
retrospect my views on that haven't
changed except for the fact that I
recognize maybe it's it's just
impossible given the nature of people's
response to that kind of
Demand right we live in a society that's
just not going to lock down unless the
pandemic is much more deadly right so
that's a point I made which you know was
maliciously clipped out from some other
podcast where someone's trying to make
it look like I want to see children die
look there's a Pity more children didn't
die from covet right
um this is uh it was actually the same
person who who uh and that's the other
thing that got so um
poisoned here it's like that person this
this psychopath or effective psychopath
who's creating these clips of me on
podcasts the second clip of me uh
seeming to say that I wish more children
died during covet which but it was it
was so I was so it was so clear in
context what I was saying that even the
clip betrayed the context so it didn't
actually work this psycho and again I
don't know whether he actually is a
psychopath but he's behaving like one
because of the incentives of Twitter
this is somebody who Brett signal
boosted as a as a very reliable source
of information right he he kept
retweeting this guy at me against me
right and this guy at one glance I knew
how unreliable this guy was right but I
think I
I'm not at all set one thing I think I
did wrong one thing that I do regret one
thing I have not sorted out for myself
is how to navigate the the
professional and personal pressure
that gets
applied at this moment where you have a
friend or an acquaintance or someone you
know
who's behaving badly in public or or
Behaving Badly behaving in a way that
you think is bad in public
and they have a public platform where
they're influencing a lot of people and
you have your own public platform where
you're constantly getting asked to
comment on what this this friend or or
acquaintance or colleague is doing
I haven't known what I think is
ethically right about the choices that
seem forced on us and at moments like
this so like I've criticized you in
public about your interview with Kanye
now in the case in in that case I
reached out to you in private first and
told you exactly what I thought and then
when I was going to get asked in public
or when I was touching that topic on my
uh podcast I more or less said the same
thing that I said to you in private
right now that was how I navigated that
moment
um I did the same thing with you with
Elon uh at least on at the beginning
um
you know this we have we have maintained
Good Vibes that was just which is not
what I know Elon but I don't think I I
disagree with you because Good Vibes in
the moment there's a deep core of Good
Vibes that persists through time between
you and Elon and I would argue probably
between some of the other folks you
mentioned I I think with Brett I failed
to reach out in private
uh to the degree that I should have and
we never really had a we we had tried to
set up a conversation in private that
that never happened but
um there was some communication but
it would have been much better for me to
have made more of an effort in private
than I did before it's Spilled Out into
public and I would say that's true with
other people as well
what kind of interaction in private do
you think you should have with Brett
because my case would be beforehand and
now still the case I would like in this
part of the criticism
you sent my way maybe it's useful to go
to that direction actually let's go to
that direction because I think I
disagree with your criticism as you
stated publicly but this is something
you're of your country the thing you
criticized me for is actually the right
thing to do with Brett okay you you said
Lex could have spoken with Kanye in such
a way as to have produced a useful
document he didn't do that because he
has a fairly naive philosophy about the
power of love
let's see if you can maintain that
philosophy in the presence let's go
no it's beautiful he seemed to think
that if he just got through the
Minefield to the end of the conversation
where the two of them still were feeling
good about one another and they can hug
it out that would be by definition a
success so
let me make the case for this Power of
Love philosophy right and first of all I
love you Sam you're still an inspiration
and somebody I deeply admire okay back
at you uh the to me in the case of Kanye
it's not only that you get to the
conversation and have hugs it's that the
display that you're willing to do that
has power so even if it doesn't end in
hugging the actual the turning the other
cheek the act of turning the other cheek
itself communicates both to Kanye later
and to the rest of the world
that we should
have empathy and compassion towards each
other there is power to that that maybe
that is naive but I believe in the power
of that so it's not that I'm trying to
convince Kanye that some of his ideas
are wrong but I'm trying to illustrate
that just the act of listening and truly
trying to understand another human being
that is opens people's minds to actually
questioning their own beliefs more it
takes them out of the dogmatism
de-escalates the kind of uh dogmatism
that I've been seeing so in that sense I
would say the Power of Love is is the is
the philosophy you might apply to Brett
because the right conversation you have
in private is not about Hey listen
you're you know the the experts you're
talking to they seem credentialed but
they're not actually as Kardashians as
they're illustrating they're not
grounding their findings in an actual
meta-analyzes and papers and so on like
making a strong case like what are you
doing there's going to get a lot of
people in trouble but instead just
saying like being a friend in the
dumbest of ways being like
respectful sending love their way and
just having a conversation outside of
all of this outside like basically so
showing that like
removing the emotional attachment to
this debate even though you are very
emotionally attached because in the case
of covid specifically there is a very
large number of lies at stake
but removing all of that and remembering
that you have a friendship
yeah well so I think these are highly
non-analogous cases right so your
conversation with Kanye
misfired from my point of view for a
very different reason it was it was
it has to do with Kanye I mean so Kanye
I don't know I've never met Kanye so
obviously I don't know him
um but
I think he's either obviously in the
midst of a mental health crisis
or he's a colossal [__]
or both I mean there's actually those
aren't mutually exclusive so one of
three possibilities he's either mentally
ill he's an [__] or he's a he's
mentally ill and an [__] I think all
three of those possibilities are
possible for the both of us as well no
moment I would argue none of those are
are likely for either of us but
um possible not to say we don't have our
moments but
so so the reason not to talk to Kanye so
you I think you should have had the
conversation you had with him in private
that's great and there's no I've got no
uh criticism
of what you said had it been in private
in Pub I just thought
you're not doing him a favor if he's
mentally ill right
if he's in the middle of a a manic
episode or or you know I'm not a
clinician but I've heard it said of him
that he is bipolar um you're not doing
him a favor sticking a mic in front of
him and letting him go off on the Jews
or anything else right
um we know what he thought about the
Jews we know that there's not much
illumination going to cut it's going to
come from him on that topic and if it is
a symptom of his mental illness that he
thinks these things well then it's
you're not doing him a favor making that
even more public
um if he's just an [__] and he's just
an anti-semite in an ordinary you know
Garden variety anti-semite well then
there's also not much to say unless
you're really going to dig in and kick
the [__] out of him in public and I'm
saying you can do that with love I mean
that's the other thing here is that
I don't agree that compassion and love
always have this patient
embracing acquiescence
face right they don't always feel good
to the recipient right there is a sword
of wisdom that you can wield
compassionately in moments like that
where someone's full of [__] and you
just make it absolutely clear to them
and to your audience that they're full
of [__] and it's no there's no hatred
being communicated in fact you could
just it's like listen I'm going to do
everyone a favor right now and you know
just take your foot out of your mouth
and and
um
and the truth is you know I wouldn't I
just wouldn't have aired the
conversation like I just don't think it
was a document that had to get out there
right I I get that many P this is not a
signal you're likely to get from your
audience right I get that many people in
your audience thought oh my God that's
awesome you're talking to Kanye and
you're doing it in Lex style where it's
just love and you're not treating him
like a pariah and you know you're you're
holding this tension between he's this
creative genius who we lose work we love
and yet he's having this moment that's
so painful and you know what a tightrope
walk and I get that maybe 90 of your
audience saw it that way they're still
wrong and I and I still think that was
non-balanced not a good thing to put out
into the world you don't think it opens
up the mind and heart of people that
listen to that just have it it does it's
let if it's opening up in the wrong
Direction Where just gale force nonsense
is coming in right I think we should
have an open mind and an open heart but
there's some clear things here that
that we have to keep in view one is the
mental illness component is its own
thing yeah I don't pretend to understand
what's going on with him so but insofar
as that's the reason he's saying what
he's saying
do not put this guy on camera and let
know sorry on that point real quick I
had a bunch of conversation with them
offline and I didn't get a sense of
mental illness that's why I chose to sit
down okay and I didn't get it I mean
mental illness is such a
yeah
but when he shows up in a [__] put on
Alex Jones's podcast I mean this is
either that's more you know genius
performance in his world or it's he's
unraveling further I wouldn't put that
under mental illness I we have to I
think there's another conversation to be
had about
how we treat artists
right because they're they're weirdos
they're very I mean we you know taking
taking words from Kanye as if he he's
like Christopher Hitchens or something
like that like very eloquent researched
you know written many books on history
and politics and geopolitics uh
psychology kind of didn't do any of that
he's an artist just spotting off and so
there's a different style conversation
and a different way to treat
the words that are coming out let's
leave the mental illness aside so if
we're going to say that there's no
reason to think he's mentally ill and
this is just him being creative and
Brilliant and opinionated
well then that falls into the [__]
bucket for me it's like then then he's
someone and honestly the most offensive
thing about him in that interview from
my point of view is not the
anti-Semitism which you know we can talk
about because I think there there are
problems just letting him uh
spread those memes as well but the most
offensive thing is just how delusionally
egocentric he is or was coming off in
that interview and in others like he he
has an estimation of himself as this
Omnibus genius that to to arrive not
only to rival Shakespeare to exceed
Shakespeare right I mean he's like he's
he's the greatest mind that has ever
walked Among Us and he's more or less
explicit on that point and yet he
manages to talk for hours without saying
anything actually interesting or
insightful or or factually Illuminating
right so it's complete delusion of a
very trumpian sort it's like it's like
you know when Trump says he's a genius
who understands everything but nobody
takes him seriously
and one wonders whether Trump takes
himself seriously Kanye seems to believe
he seems to believe his own press he
actually thinks he's he's you know uh
just a Colossus and
um he may be a great musician you know
I'm not you know I've
certainly not my wheelhouse to compare
him to any other musicians but
um
one thing that's patently obvious in
from your conversation is he's not who
he thinks he is intellectually or
ethically or in any other relevant way
and so when you couple that to the
anti-Semitism he was spreading which I
what was genuinely noxious and
ill-considered and
um has potential knock-on effects in the
black community I mean there's a there's
an ambient level of anti-Semitism in the
black community that is worth worrying
about and talking about anyway there's a
bunch of guys you know playing The
Knockout game in Brooklyn just punching
Orthodox Jews in the face
and I think letting Kanye air his
anti-Semitism that publicly only raises
the the likelihood of that rather than
diminishes it I don't know so let me say
just a couple of things so one my belief
at the time
was it doesn't it decreases it showing
empathy while pushing back decreases
likelihood of that it does might it
might on the surface look like it's
increasing it but that's simply because
the anti-Semitism or the hatred in
general is brought to the surface and
then people talk talk about it but I
should also say that you're one of the
only people that wrote to me privately
criticizing me and
um like out of the people I really
respect and admire and that was really
valuable that like I had to it's painful
because I had to think through it for a
while I'm still it still haunts me
because the other kind of criticism I
got a lot of people basically said
thinks towards me uh based on who I am
that they hate me just just you mean
anti-semitic things or that you're
anti-semitic because I just hate the
word anti-semitic it's a it's like
racist well but here's the reality
so I'm someone so I'm Jewish you know
although obviously not religious
um
I have never taken you know I've been a
student of the Holocaust obviously I I
know a lot about that and and there's
reason to
to be a student of the Holocaust uh but
in my lifetime and in my experience I
have never taken anti-Semitism very
seriously I'm have not worried about it
I have not
um made a thing of it I've done exactly
one podcast on it I had Barry Weiss on
my podcast
um when her book came out
but
it really is a thing and it's uh
is something we have to keep an eye on
societally because it it it's the it's a
unique kind of hatred right it's it's
Unique in that
it seems It's knit together with it's
not just ordinary racism it's knit
together with lots of conspiracy
theories that never seem to die out
um it's it can by turns equally animate
the left and the right politically and
it was so perverse about anti-Semitism
like look in the American context with
the far right you know with white
supremacists Jews aren't considered
white so they hate us and this from The
Same Spirit in which they hate black
people or brown people or anyone who's
not white
but on the left Jews are considered
extra white I mean we're we're the extra
beneficiaries of white privilege right
and in the black community that is often
the case right we're a minority that has
thrived and so and and it seems to stand
as a Counterpoint to all of the problems
of of that other minorities suffer in
particular you know African-Americans in
the American context
um and yeah Asians are now getting a
little bit of this you know like the the
model minority uh uh issue but Jews have
had this going on for centuries and and
Millennia and it never seems to go away
and it's again this is something that
I've never focused on but
this has been at a slow boil for as long
as we've been alive and there's no
guarantee it can't suddenly become much
much uglier than we have any reason to
to expect it to become Even in our
society and so
um there's a there's kind of a special
concern at moments like that where you
have an immensely influential person in
a community
who already has a checkered history with
respect to their own beliefs about the
Jews and the conspiracies and all the
rest
and he's just messaging uh you know not
especially fully opposed by you and
anyone else who's given him the
microphone at that moment
to the world and that so that that
you know made my Spidey Sense yeah it's
complicated it's the stakes are very
high and as somebody that's been
obviously family and also reading a lot
about World War II and just this whole
period is a very difficult conversation
but I I I I believe in the power
especially uh given who I am of
um not always but sometimes often
turning the other cheek
oh yeah and again things change
when it when they're for public
consumption you know when you're with so
it's like I mean the the cut for me that
you know has just the use case I keep
stumbling upon is the the kinds of
things that I will say on a podcast like
this or if I'm giving a public lecture
versus the kinds of things I will say at
dinner
with strangers or with friends like like
if you're in an Elevate like if I'm in
an elevator with strangers I do not fee
and I hear someone say something stupid
I don't feel a an intellectual
responsibility to turn around in that
you know in the con in the confines of
that space with them and say listen that
thing you just said about X Y or Z is
completely false and here's why right
but if somebody says it in front of me
uh on some public bias where I'm
actually talking about ideas that's when
you know there's a different
responsibility that comes online the
question is how you say it how you say
it or even whether you say anything in
in those I mean there are moments there
there are definitely moments to
privilege civility or just to pick your
battles I mean sometimes it's just not
worth it to get into it with somebody
out out in in real life I just believe
in the power of empathy both in the pre
in the elevator and when a bunch of
people are listening
that when they see you willing to
consider the another human being's
perspective
it just gives more power to your
to your words after
well yeah but until it doesn't like if
because you can
you can right you can extend charity too
far right you could like it can be
absolutely obvious what someone's
motives really are and they're they're
you know dissembling about that right
and so then you're taking it face value
their representations begins to look
like you're just being duped and you're
not you're not actually doing the work
of of putting pressure on a bad actor
you know so it's it's and again the
whole the mental illness component here
makes makes it very difficult to think
about what you should or shouldn't have
said to Kanye so I think the topic of
platform is is pretty interesting
um like what's your view on uh
platforming controversial people let's
let's start with the uh the old would
you interview Hitler
on your podcast and how would you talk
to them oh and follow-up question would
you interview him in 1935
uh 41
and then like 45 well we have an uncanny
valley problem with respect to this
issue of
whether or not to speak to bad people
right so if a person is sufficiently bad
right if they're all the way out of the
valley
then you can talk to them and it's just
it's totally unproblematic to talk to
them because you don't have to spend any
time signaling to your audience that you
don't agree with them and if you're
interviewing Hitler you don't have to
say listen I just got to say before we
start I don't agree with the whole you
know genocide thing and you know I just
think you're uh killing you know killing
mental patients and vans and all that
that was all bad it's a bad look
Adolf uh so you you just it can go
without saying that you don't agree with
this person and you're not platforming
them to signal boost their
their views you're just trying to if
they're sufficiently evil you can go
into it very much as an anthropologist
would
uh just you just want to understand the
nature of evil right you just want to
understand this phenomenon like how is
this person who they are right
um and that strikes me as a
intellectually interesting and
and morally necessary thing to do right
so yes you I think you always interview
Hitler
really happening
if you're on the cusp of it where it's
just he's someone who's gaining power
and you don't want to you don't want to
help facilitate that
um then there's a question of whether
you can you can undermine him in while
pushing back against him in that
interview right so there are people I
wouldn't talk to just because I don't
want to give them oxygen and I don't
think that in the in the context of my
interviewing them I'm going to be able
to to take the wind out of their sails
at all right so it's like for whatever
either because in asymmetric Advantage
because I just know that they can
do something that they they within the
span of an hour that I can't that I
can't correct for sure you know is it's
like they can they can light many small
fires and it just takes too much time to
put them in that's more like on the
topic of vaccines for example having a
debate on the efficacy of vaccines yeah
okay it's not that I don't think
sunlight is usually the best
disinfectant I think it is you know even
these asymmetries aside I mean there are
there it is true that a person can
always make a mess faster than you can
clean it up right but still their
debates worth having even given that
limitation
um and they're the right people to have
those specific debates and there's so
there's certain topics where you know
I'll debate someone just because
I'm the right person for the job and it
doesn't matter how messy they're going
to be I it's just it's just worth it
because I can make my points land at
least to the right part of the audience
so some of it is just your own skill and
competence and also interest in
preparing correctly well yeah yeah and
the nature of the subject matter and and
uh
but yeah but there are other people who
just by default I would say well there's
no reason to give this guy a platform
and there are also people who are so
confabulatory that
they're making such a mess with every
sentence
uh that you in so far as you're even
trying to interact with what they're
saying
you're going You're by definition going
to fail and you're going to seem to fail
to an unsufficiently large uninformed
audience where it's going to be a net
negative for for the for the cause of
truth no matter how good you are so like
for instance I think
talking to Alex Jones on any topic for
any reason is probably a bad idea
because I just think he's he's just
neurologically wired
to just I mean utter a string of
sentences he'll get 20 sentences out
Each of which has to be Each of which is
you know contains more lives than the
last
and
there's just there's not time enough in
the world to run down and certainly not
time enough in the span of a
conversation to run down each of those
leads to to bedrock so as to falsify it
I mean they'll just make [__] up they
just and or and or make [__] up and then
then weave it in with with you know half
truths and and and micro truths that
give some semblance of credibility to
somebody out there I mean apparently
millions of people out there
um and there's just no way to to
untangle that in real time with him I
have noticed that you have an allergic
reaction to
confabulatorization yeah confabulation
confabulation that if somebody
says something a little micro untruth
it really stops your brain here I'm not
talking about micro intrudes I'm just
talking about making up things out of
whole cloth just like is it if someone
says some people like well what about
and then then the thing they put
at the end of that sentence is just a
set of pseudo facts right that you can't
possibly authenticate or not in the span
of that conversation
they will you know whether it's about
UFOs or anything else right
they will seem to make you look like an
ignoramus when in fact everything
they're saying is specious right whether
they know it or not I mean there's some
people who are just crazy there's some
people who are
who are just bullshitting and they're
not even tracking whether it's true it
just feels good and then some people are
consciously lying about things but don't
you think there's just a kind of jazz
Masterpiece of untruth that you should
be able to just wave off by saying like
well none of that is backed up by any
evidence they just almost like take it
to the humor place and then but the
thing is
the place I'm familiar with doing this
and not doing this is is um
on specific conspiracies like 9 11 truth
right like the 911 so I because of my
because of what 9 11 did to my
uh intellectual life I mean it's really
just you know it it sent me down a path
for the better part of a decade like I
became a Critic of religion
when I don't know if I was ever going to
be a Critic of religion right like but
that like it happened to be in my
wheelhouse because I spent so much time
studying religion
uh on my own and I was um also very
interested in in the the underlying
spiritual concerns of every religion and
so I was I was um
you know
I devoted
more than a full decade of my life to
just you know what is what is real here
what is possible what is what is the
nature of subjective reality and how
does it relate to reality at large and
is there anything to
you know who just who was someone like
Jesus or Buddha and are these people
frauds are they are they are this just
uh these just myths or or or is there
really a Continuum of of insight to be
had here that is interesting so I spent
a lot of time on that question
through my 20 the full decade in my 20s
and that was launched in part by 9 11
truth or no but then when 9 11 happened
I had spent all this time you know
reading religious books understanding
empathically understanding the
motivations of religious people right
knowing just how fully certain people
believe what they say they believe right
so I took religious convictions very
seriously
and then people started flying planes
into our buildings and I so I knew that
there was something to be said about
allegedly the the core doctrines of
Islam exactly
so so I went down so that was that
became my wheelhouse for a time
um you know terrorism and and uh
jihadism and related topics and so the
911 truth conspiracy thing kept you know
uh getting aimed at me
and
the question was well do I do I want to
debate these people right like Alex
Jones perhaps yeah I mean yeah so Alex
Jones I think was an early purveyor of
it although I don't think I knew who he
was at that point
um
and so and privately I had some very
long debates with people who you know
one person in my family went way down
that rabbit hole and I just you know
every six months or so I'd literally
write the two-hour email you know that
would try to
try to deprogram them you know however
ineffectually and
uh so I went back and forth three years
on that topic with with in private with
people but I could see the structure of
the conspiracy I could see the nature of
of of of of how
of how impossible it was to
to play whack-a-mole sufficiently well
so as to so as to convince anyone of
anything who was who was
not seeing
the
the problematic structure of that way of
thinking I mean it's not actually a
thesis it's a it's a proliferation of
anomalies that don't you can't actually
connect all the dots that are being
pointed to they don't connect in a
coherent way there's they're
incompatible
Theses that are not and their
incompatibility is not being
acknowledged
um but they're they're running this
algorithms of things are things are
never what they seem there's always
malicious conspirators doing things
perfectly that we we see all we see
evidence of human incompetence
everywhere else no one can tie their
shoes you know expertly anywhere else
but over here
people are perfectly competent they're
perfectly concealing they like the
thousands of people are collaborating
you know inexplicably I mean
incentivized by what who knows they're
they're collaborating to murder
thousands of their neighbors and no one
is breathing a peep about it no one's
getting caught on up on camera no one's
you know no one's breathed the word of
it to a journalist
um
and
so
I've I've dealt with that style of
thinking and I've I know what it's like
to be in the weeds of a conversation
like that and and the person will say
okay well but what do you make of the
fact that um all those f-16s were flown
800 miles out to sea on the morning of 9
11 to doing an exercise that hadn't even
been scheduled for that day but it was
and now all of these are I dimly recall
some thesis of that kind but I'm just
making these things up now right so I
got that detail hadn't even been
scheduled for that day it was
inexplicably run that day like so what
how long would it take to track that
down right the idea that this is
anomalous like that there was a f f 16
uh exercise run
on it on and it wasn't even supposed to
be run that day right
someone like Alex Jones their speech
pattern is to pack as much of that stuff
in as possible at the highest velocity
that a person can speak and unless
you're knocking down each one of those
things to that audience you appear to
just be uninformed you appear to just
not be you don't he didn't know about
the f-16s yeah
um sure he he doesn't know what project
Mockingbird you haven't heard about
project Mockingbird I just made up
project Mockingbird I don't know what it
is but
that's the kind of thing that comes at
tumbling out in a conversation like that
that's the kind of thing frankly I was
worried about in the covet conversation
because not that someone like Brett
would do it consciously but someone like
Brett is swimming in a sea of
misinformation on social living on
Twitter getting people sending the blog
post and the study from
from uh you know the Philippines that
showed that in this cohort Ivermectin
did X right and
and not like
to actually run anything to ground right
you have to actually do the work
journalistically and scientifically
and run it to ground right so sort of
many for some of these questions you
actually have to be a statistician to
say okay
they were they used the wrong statistics
in this experiment right now
yes we could take all the time to do
that or we could at every stage along
the way
in a in a context where we we have
experts we can trust go with 97 what 97
of the experts are saying about X about
the safety of mRNA about the
transmissibility of covet about whether
to wear a mask or not wear masks and I
completely agree that that broke down
uh
unacceptably in the over the last few
years and that but I think that's
largely a social media and blogs and and
the efforts of podcasters and sub stack
writers
were not just a response to that it was
a I think it was a it was a symptom of
that and a cause of that right and I
think we're living in a an environment
where
people we've basically we have trained
ourselves not to be able to agree about
facts on any topic no matter how urgent
right what's what's flying in our Sky
you know what is you know what is what's
happening in Ukraine is is Putin just uh
denotsifying Ukraine I mean like they're
people who we respect
who are spending time down that
particular Rabbit Hole like this is
this is you know maybe there are a lot
of Nazis in Ukraine and that's the real
problem
right maybe Putin's
maybe Putin's not the bad actor here
right how much time do I have to spend
empathizing with Putin to the point of
thinking well maybe Putin's got a point
and it's it's like what about the
polonium and the nerve agents and the
killing of journalists and the you know
navalny and like does that count well no
listen I'm not paying so much attention
to that because I'm following all these
interesting people on Twitter and
they're giving me some Pro Putin
material here and there is a there are
some Nazis in Ukraine it's not like
there are no Nazis in Ukraine how am I
going to weight these things
I think people are being driven Crazy by
Twitter yeah but you're you're kind of
speaking to conspiracy theories that
pollute everything and then but every
every example you gave is kind of a bad
faith
style of conversation but but it's not
necessarily knowingly bad faith by I
mean the people the people who are who
are worried about Ukraine Ukrainian
Nazis
to my I mean they're some of the same
people they're the same people who are
worried about
Ivermectin got suppressed like
Ivermectin is really the Panacea but it
got suppressed for because no one could
make billions on it
um
it's the same it's literally this in
many cases the same people and the same
efforts to to unearth those and you're
saying it's very difficult to have
conversations with those kinds of people
what about
uh conversation with Trump himself would
you do a podcast with Trump
no I I don't think so I don't think I'd
be learning anything about him it's like
with with Hitler and I'm not comparing
Trump to Hitler but Clips guy is your
chance you got this one with certain
world historical figures
um
I would just feel like okay this is an
opportunity to learn something that I'm
not going to learn I think Trump is
among the most superficial people we've
ever laid eyes on right like he is he is
in public view right and
I'm sure I'm sure there's some distance
between who he is in private and who he
is in public but it's not going to be
the kind of distance that's going to
blow my mind
um and I think
so I think the liability so for instance
I think Joe Rogan was
very wise not to have Trump on his
podcast
I think all he would have been doing is
is he would have put himself in a
situation where he couldn't adequately
contain the damage Trump was doing and
he was just going to make Trump seem
cool to a whole new
you know a potentially new cohort of his
massive audience right
um
I mean they would have they would have
had a lot of laughs Trump's funny
I mean the
entertainment value of things is so
uh influential
I mean it was that one debate where
Trump uh you know got a massive laugh on
the you know his line you know only
Rosie O'Donnell right
the truth is we're living in a political
system where if you can get a big laugh
during a political debate you win
it doesn't matter who you are like
that's the level of of you know it
doesn't matter how uninformed you are it
doesn't matter that half the debate was
about what the hell we should do about
about uh
you know a threat of nuclear war or
anything else
um
it's
we're monkeys right and we like to laugh
well because you brought up Joe he's
somebody like you I look up to
uh I've learned a lot from him because I
think
who he is privately is a human being
also his he's kind of the voice of
curiosity to me he inspired me that's an
unending open-minded curiosity
um much like you are the voice of reason
uh they recently had a podcast Joe had
recent a podcast of Jordan Peterson and
I have brought you up saying they still
have a hope for you yeah uh any chance
any chance you talk to Joe again and
reinvigorate your friendship
you get well I reached out to him
privately when I saw that did you use
the power of love
Joe knows I love him and consider him a
friend right so there's no there's no
issue there
um he also knows I'll I'll be happy to
do his podcast uh
when we get that together you know so
there's no I've got no policy of not
talking to Joe or not doing his podcast
um
I mean I think we're we got a little
sideways along these same lines where
you know we've talked about Brett and
Elon and other people
um it was never
to that degree with Joe because
um
Joe's in a very different Lane right
he's unconsciously so I mean Joe is a
stand-up comic who interviews who just
is interested in it in everything
interviews the widest conceivable
variety of people
and just lets his interests collide with
their expertise or you know lack of
expertise I mean he's he's again it's a
super wide variety of people
um he'll talk about anything and he can
always pull the rip cord saying
you know I don't know what the [__] I'm
saying I'm a comic I'm stoned we just
drank too much right like like it's very
entertaining it's all in you know to my
eye it's it's all in good faith I think
Joe is an extraordinarily ethical good
person also doesn't use Twitter doesn't
really use it yeah yeah no The crucial
difference though is it because he
is
an Entertainer first I mean I'm not
saying he's not smart and he doesn't
understand things he I mean what's
potentially confusing he's very smart
and he's he's also very informed he's he
his full-time job is taught you know
when he's not doing stand-up we're doing
color commentary for the UFC
his full-time job is talking to lots of
very smart people at Great length so
he's he's created a you know the Joe
Rogan University for himself and he's
gotten a lot of information uh crammed
into his head so it's not that he's
uninformed but he can always when he
feels that he's uninformed or when it
turns out he was wrong about something
he can always pull the rip cord and say
I I'm just a comic we were stoned it was
fun you know don't don't take medical
advice from me I don't play a doctor on
the internet right
um
I can't quite do that right you can't
quite do that we're in different Lanes
I'm not saying you you and I are in
exactly the same Lane but for much of
Joe's audience I'm just this
establishment shill is just banging on
about you know the universities and
medical journals and and
um it's not true but that would be the
perception and as a Counterpoint to a
lot of what's being said on Joe's
podcast or or uh you know certainly
Brett's podcast on these topics I can
see how they they would form that
opinion but
in reality if you listen to me long
enough you hear that
I've said as much against the woke
nonsense as anyone even any lunatic on
the right who's can only keep that
bright that bright shiny object in view
right
um so there's nothing that Candace Owens
has said about wokeness that I haven't
said about wokeness as far insofar as
she's speaking rationally about wokeness
um
but
we have to be able to keep multiple
things in view right if you if you could
only look at the problem of wokeness and
you couldn't acknowledge the problem of
trump and trumpism and Q Anon and and
the explosion of irrationality that was
happening on the right and bigotry that
was happening on the right
um you just you were just disregarding
half of the landscape and many people
took half of the problem
in in recent years the last five years
is a story of many people taking half of
the problem and monetizing that half of
the problem and and getting captured by
an audience that only wanted that half
of the problem talked about in that way
and um
this is the larger issue of of uh
audience capture which you know is very
I'm sure it's
it's an ancient problem but um it's a
very helpful phrase that I think comes
to us courtesy of our mutual friend Eric
Weinstein and
audience captures a thing and I believe
I've witnessed many you know casualties
of it and if there's anything I've been
on guard against in my life you know
professionally it's been that and and
when I noticed that I had a lot of
people in my audience
who didn't like my criticizing Trump
I really leaned into it and when I
noticed that a lot of the other cohort
in my audience didn't like me
criticizing the far left and wokeness I
thought I was you know exaggerating that
problem I leaned into it because I
thought those parts of my audience were
were absolutely wrong and I didn't care
about whether I was going to lose those
parts of my audience there are people
who have created you know
knowingly or not they're people who've
created different incentives for
themselves because how they they've
monetized their podcasts and because of
the kind of signal they've responded to
In Their audience
um and I worry about you know I know
Brett would consider this a totally
invidious
uh ad hominem thing to say but I really
do worry that that's happened to Brett I
think I think I I cannot explain how you
do a hundred with all the things in the
in the universe to be interested in
and of all the things he's competent to
speak intelligently about I don't know
how you do a hundred podcasts in a row
on on covet right it's just it makes no
sense you think um in part audience
capture can explain that I absolutely
think it can yeah what about
do you like for example do you feel
pressure
to not admit that you made a mistake on
covet or made a mistake on Trump
I'm not saying you feel that way but do
you feel this pressure so you've
attacked audience capture within
yourself within the way you do stuff so
you don't feel as much pressure from the
audience but within your own ego
I mean again the people who think I'm
wrong about any of these topics are
going to think okay you're just
not admitting that you're wrong but then
now we're having a dispute about
specific facts
um
there are there are things that I
believed about covet or worried might
very might be true about covet two years
ago that I no longer believe or I'm not
so worried about now and and vice versa
I mean like the things are flipped
certain things are flipped upside down
um
the question is was I wrong so here's a
here's the cartoon version of it but
this is something I said probably 18
months ago and it's still true
you know when I saw what Brett was doing
on covid you know
let's call it two years ago
I I said even if he's right even if he
turned if even turns out that Ivermectin
is a Panacea
and the MRNA vaccines kill millions of
people right he's still wrong right now
his reasoning is still flawed right now
his facts still suck right now right and
his and his confidence is is unjustified
now that was true then that will always
be true then right and and so
and not much has changed for me to to
revisit
any of my time points along the way
again I will totally concede that if I
had teenage boys and their Dot and their
schools were demanding that they'd be
vaccinated with the MRNA vaccine
I would I would be powerfully annoyed
right I like I would I wouldn't know
what I was going to do and I would be I
would be doing more research about about
myocarditis and I'd be badgering our
doctors and I would be worried that we
have a medical system and a
pharmaceutical system and a Health Care
system and a public health system that's
not incentivized to to look at any of
this in a fine-grained way and they just
want one uh blanket admonition to the
entire population just get just take the
shot you idiots
uh I view that largely as a result a
panicked response to the misinformation
explosion that happened and the public
the populist resistance animated but
misinformation that just made it
impossible to get anyone to to cooperate
right so it was just part of it is again
a pendulum swing in the wrong direction
if someone analogous to the woke
responds to Trump and the trumpist
response to woke right so there's a lot
of people have just gotten pushed around
for bad reasons or but understandable
reasons but
yes
it's there are there are caveats to my
things have changed about my view of
covid but the question is if you roll
back the clock 18 months was I wrong to
want to platform
uh Eric topel you know a a very well
respected cardiologist on this topic or
you know Nicholas christakis to to talk
about the network effects of you know
the you know whether we should close
schools right he's written a book on
covid he's you know Network effects or
his wheelhouse as it both as an MD and
as a sociologist
um
there was a lot that we believed we knew
about the efficacy of of closing schools
during pandemics right during the you
know during the
the Spanish Flu pandemic and others
right but there's a lot we didn't know
about covet we didn't know we didn't
know how
uh
negligible the effects would be on kids
compared to older people we didn't know
it like so my problem I really enjoyed
your conversation with Eric Topo but
also didn't
so he is one of the Great communicators
in many ways on Twitter like
distillation of the current data but he
I hope I'm not overstating it but
there is a bit of an arrogance
from him that I think it could be
explained by him being exhausted by
being constantly attacked by conspiracy
theory like anti-vaxxers yeah
to me the same thing happens with people
that start drifting to be being right
wing
is to get attacked so much by the left
they become almost irrational and
arrogant in their beliefs and I I felt
your conversation with Eric topple did
not sufficiently empathize with people
that have skepticism but also did not
sufficiently communicate uncertainty we
have so like the many of the decisions
you made many of the things you were
talking about
we're kind of saying there's a lot of
uncertainty but this is the best thing
we can do now well it was a forest
Choice you're going to get covid do you
want to be vaccinated when you get it
right that was always
in my view an easy choice
and it's up until you you start breaking
apart the cohorts and you start saying
okay wait a minute there is this
myocarditis issue in in young men let's
talk about that
when that's before that story emerged it
was just it was just clear that
this is
if it's not if it's not knocking down
transmission as much as we had hoped it
is still mitigating severe illness and
death
uh and
I I still believe that it is the the
current view of the of
most people competent to analyze the
data that we lost something like 300 000
people unnecessarily in the US because
of because of vaccine hesitancy but I
think there's a way to communicate with
humility about the uncertainty of things
that would increase the vaccination rate
I do believe that it is
rational and sometimes effective
to to Signal impatience with certain
bad ideas right and certain conspiracy
theories and certain forms of
misinformation I think so because it's
just I just think it makes you look a
douchebag most times well I mean certain
people are persuadable certain people
are not not persuadable but
it's um no because there's not enough
it's the opportunity cost not everything
can be
given a patient hearing it's like you
can't have a physics conference and then
let people in to just trumpet their pet
theories about you know the grand
unified vision of physics
um when they're obviously crazy or
they're obviously half crazy or they're
just not you know the the people like
you begin to you begin to get a sense
for this it when it is your wheelhouse
but there are people who
kind of declare their their
irrelevance to the conversation fairly
quickly without knowing that they have
done it right and uh
and the truth is I think I'm one of
those people on the topic of covet right
like I it's like it's not it's never
that I felt listen
I know exactly what's going on here I
know these mRNA vaccines are safe I know
exactly I know I know exactly how to run
a lockdown I
no this is this is a situation where you
want the actual Pilots to fly the plane
right we needed experts who we could
trust and insofar as our experts got
captured by by all manner of thing I
mean some of them got captured by Trump
some of them were made to look
ridiculous just standing next to Trump
while he was bloviating about you know
whatever that you know it's just going
to go away there's just 15 people you
know there's 15 people in a cruise ship
and it's just going to go away there's
gonna be no problem or it's like when he
said that he you know many of these
doctors think I understand this better
than them they're just amazed at how I
understand this and you've got doctors
real doctors the heads of the CDC and
and NIH standing around just ashen-faced
while he's talking you know
um all of this was deeply corrupt in of
the Public Communication of science on
both and then again I've banged on about
the
depredations of wokeness the woke thing
was a disaster or it still is a disaster
but it doesn't mean
that I mean but the thing is there's a
big difference between me and Brett in
this case I didn't do 100 podcasts on
covid I did like two podcasts on covet
the measure of my concern about covid
can be measured in how many podcasts I
did on it right it's like once we had a
sense of how to live with covid
I was just living with covet right like
okay if you get facts or don't get
vaxxed wear a mask or don't wear a mask
travel or don't travel like you've got a
few things to decide but
my kids were stuck at home on iPads you
know for too long I didn't agree with
that it was obviously not functional
like I criticize that on the margins but
there was not much to do about it but
the the thing I didn't do is make this
my life and just brow beat people with
one message or another
we need a public health regime
where we can trust what the competent
people are saying to us about you know
what medicines are safe to take and in
the absence of that
craziness is going to even in the
presence of that craziness is going to
proliferate given the tools we've built
but in the absence of that it's going to
proliferate for understandable reasons
and that's gonna
it's it's not going to be good next time
when when something orders of magnitude
more dangerous hits us and that's
I spent you know insofar as I think
about this issue I think much more about
next time than this time
before this covid thing you and Brad had
some good conversations I would say
we're friends what's your what do you
admire most about Brett outside of all
the criticism we've had about this covet
topic
well I think Brett is very smart and
he's a very um ethical person who wants
good things for the world I mean I have
no reason to doubt that so the fact that
we're on you know we're cross-wise on
this issue is not does not mean that I
think he's
a bad person I mean the thing that
worried me about what he was doing
and this was true of Joe and this was
true of Elon this is true of many other
people is that once you're messaging at
scale
to a vast audience
you incur a certain kind of
responsibility not to to get people
killed and I do I did worry that
yeah people were people were making
decisions on the basis of the
information that was getting shared
there and that that's why I was
I think fairly circumspect I just said
okay give me the the
center of the Fairway expert opinion at
this time point and at this time point
at this time point
and then I'm out right I don't have any
more to say about this I'm not an expert
on covet I'm not an expert on the safety
of mRNA vaccines
um
if something if something changes so is
to become newsworthy then maybe I'll do
a podcast so I just did a podcast on
collably right like I was never
skeptical of the lab Lake hypothesis
Brett was very early on saying this is
this is a lab leak right
um at a point where my only position was
who cares if it's elaborate right like
this there's the thing we have to get
straight is what do we do given the
nature of this pandemic but also we
should say that you've actually stated
that it is a possibility oh yeah you
just said it doesn't doesn't it I mean
it the time to figure that out now I've
actually I have had my my podcast guest
on this topic changed my view of this
because you know one of the guests uh
Elena Chan made the point that you know
actually that the best time to figure
out the origin of this is immediately
right because in the Abbott you lose
touch with the evidence and I hadn't
really been thinking about that like I
didn't if you come back after a year
um
you know there are certain facts you
might not be able to get in hand but
I've always felt that
it didn't matter for two reasons one is
we had the Genome of the virus and and
we could design we're very quickly
designed immediately designing vaccines
against that genome and that's what we
had to do and then we had to figure out
how to vaccinate and to
and to mitigate and to develop
treatments and all of that
so the origin story didn't matter
generically speaking
either or origin story
was
politically inflammatory and made the
Chinese look bad right and the Chinese
response to this looked bad whatever the
origin story right they're not
cooperating they're letting they're
stopping their domestic flights but
letting their international flights go I
mean it's just they were bad actors and
they should be treated as such
regardless of the origin right and you
know I would argue that the wet Market
origin is even more politically
invidious than the lab League origin I
mean why do you think because for lab
leak to my eye
the lab leak could happen to anyone
right we're all running all these
Advanced countries are running these
dangerous labs
that's a practice that we should be
worried about you know in general
we know lab leaks are a problem there
have been multiple lab leaks of even
worse things that haven't gotten out of
hand in this way but you know worse
pathogens
um
we're
we're wise to be worried about this and
on some level it could happen to anyone
right the wet Market makes them look
like barbarians live in another Century
like you got to clean up those wet
markets like what the you what are you
doing putting a bat on top of a Pangolin
on top of a duck it's like get your [__]
together so like if anything
the wet Market makes them look worse in
my view now I'm sure there's I'm sure
that what they actually did to conceal a
lab leak if it was a lab League all of
that's going to look odious
um do you think we'll ever get to the
bottom of that I mean one of the big
negative
um I would say failures of Anthony fauci
and so on is to be transparent and clear
and it's just a good communicator about
getting functional research the dangers
of that the success like the you know
why it's a useful way of research but
it's also dangerous right you know just
being transparent about that as opposed
to just coming off really shady of
course the conspiracy theorists and the
the politicians are not helping but this
just created a
giant mess yeah no I would agree that so
that exchange with fauci and Rand Paul
they went viral yeah I would agree that
fauci looked like he was
taking refuge in kind of very lawyered
language
and not
giving a straightforward account of what
we do and why we do it and so yeah I
think it looked Shady it played shady
and it probably was shady I mean I don't
know how personally entangled he is with
any of this but
yeah the the gain of function research
is something that
I think we're wise to be worried about
and insofar as I judge myself adequate
to have an opinion on this
I think it should be banned right like I
I I'm probably a podcast I'll do you
know if you or somebody else doesn't do
it in the meantime
um
you know I I would like a virologist on
to defend it against a virologist who
who who would uh criticize it forget
about the gain of function research
I don't even understand virus hunting at
this point it's like I don't know I
don't even know why you need to go into
a cave to find this next virus that
could be circulating among bats that may
jump zoonotically to us
why do that when we can make when we
when we can seek once in a day and and
make vaccines in a weekend I mean like
like what kind of Head Start do you
think you're getting that's a surprising
new thing how quickly you can develop a
vaccine exactly that's uh
yeah that's that's really interesting
but the shadiness around lab League
I think the point I didn't make about
Brett's style of engaging this issue is
people are using the fact that he was
early on lab leak to suggest that he was
right about Ivermectin and about mRNA
vaccines and all the rest like no that
that's
none of that connects and it was
possible to be falsely confident like
you shouldn't have been confident about
lab no one should have been confident
about lab leak early even if it turns
out to be lap league right it was always
plausible it was never definite it still
isn't definite zoonotic is is is also
quite plausible it certainly was super
plausible then
um both are politically
uncomfortable uh both were both at the
time were inflammatory to be banging on
about when we were trying to secure some
kind of cooperation from the Chinese
right so there's a time for these things
and and
and it's possible to be right by
accident right that's the that is
it Matt you're you're reasoning the
style of reasoning matters whether
you're right or not
you know it's like because your style of
reasoning is dictating what you're going
to do on the next topic
sure but this is a
this multivariate situation here it's
really difficult to know what's right on
covid given all the uncertainty all the
chaos especially when you step outside
the pure biology virology of it and you
started getting to policy yeah that's
really yeah it's just trade-offs yeah
like transmissibility of the virus
sure just knowing
if 65 of the population gets vaccinated
what effect would that have
just even knowing those things just
modeling all those things
um
given all the other incentives I mean
Pfizer
but yeah you had the CEO advisor on your
podcast did you leave that conversation
feeling like
this is a person who is consciously
uh
reaping windfall profits on a dangerous
uh vaccine and put in everyone at
intolerable risk or do you think this
person did you think this person was
making a good faith attempt to save
lives uh and had no
no bad no no uh taint of bad incentives
or something uh the thing I sensed and I
felt in part
it was a failure on my part
but I I sense that I was talking to a
politician
so it's not thinking of there was
malevolence there or benevolence
there was uh he just had a job he put on
a suit and I was talking to a suit not a
human being
now he said that his son was a big fan
of the podcast which is why he wanted to
do it so I thought I would be talking to
a human being and I asked challenging
questions but I thought the internet
thinks otherwise every single question
in that interview
was a challenging one
but it wasn't grilling which is what
people seem to want to do with
pharmaceutical companies there's a deep
distrust of pharmaceutical companies
what's the alternative I mean I I
totally get right that windfall profits
at a time of of you know Public Health
Emergency looks bad it's a bad it is a
bad look right but yeah what do how do
we
reward
and return Capital to to to Risk Takers
who are who will spend a billion dollars
to design a new drug for a disease
that maybe only harms of you know a
single digit percentage of the
populations like well what do we want to
encourage and who do we want to get rich
I mean so like the person who cures
cancer
do we want that person to get rich or
not we want the we want the person who
uh
gave us the iPhone to get rich but we
don't want the person who who cures
cancer to get rich what what are we
trying I think it's a very gray area so
what we want is the person who declares
that they have a cure for cancer to have
authenticity and transparency this like
I think we're good now as a population
smelling [__]
and there is something about the the
Pfizer CEO for example just CEO is a
pharmaceutical companies in general just
because
they're so lowered up so much marketing
PR people that they are you just smell
[__] you're not talking to real
human that it they just it just feels
like none of it is transparent to us as
a public so like this whole
uh talking point that Pfizer is only
interested in helping people just
doesn't ring true even though it very
well could be true it's the same thing
with Bill Gates who seems to be at scale
helping a huge amount of people in the
world and yet there's something about
the way he delivers that message or
people like
they seems suspicious what's happening
underneath this right there's certain
kinds of communication styles that seem
to uh be more
uh serve as better catalysts for
conspiracy theories and I'm not sure
what what that is because I don't think
there's an alternative for capitalism
in delivering drugs that help people
but also at the same time that it seems
to need to be a more transparency and
plus like regulation that actually makes
sense versus it seems like
uh pharmaceutical companies are
susceptible to corruption
yeah I I worry about all that but I I
also do think that most of the people go
into those fields and most of the people
going into government they want to do
good doing it for good and they're
non-psychopaths trying to get good
things done and try trying to solve hard
problems and they they're not trying to
get rich I mean many of the people are
it's like
they're
bad incentives or or something again if
if you order that phrase 30 times uh on
this podcast but it's it's just almost
everywhere it explains normal people
creating terrible harm right it's not
that there are that many bad people you
know and
uh yes it makes it makes the truly bad
people that much more remarkable and
worth paying attention to but
the bad incentives and the bad and the
and the
the uh the power of bad ideas
to do much more harm because I mean
that's what that what that's what gets
good people running in the wrong
direction or or um
doing things that are that are clearly
creating unnecessary suffering
you've had and I hope still have a
friendship with Elon Musk
especially over the topic of AI you have
a lot of interesting ideas that you both
share concerns you both share uh
well let me first ask what do you admire
most about Elon
uh well you know
I had a lot of fun with Elon I like Elon
a lot I mean Elon I I knew as a friend I
I like a lot and um
uh you know you know it's it's not going
to surprise anyone I mean he's he's done
and he's continuing to do amazing things
and I think he's um
uh you know I think of many of his
aspirations are realized the world will
be a much better place I think it's it's
just it's amazing to see what he's built
and what he's attempted to build and
what he may yet build and so with Tesla
was SpaceX with yeah I'm a fan of almost
all of that
I mean there are there are wrinkles to
to a lot of that you know or some of
that
um
and humans are full of wrinkles there's
something very trumping about how he's
acting on Twitter right I mean Twitter I
think Twitter he doesn't he thinks
Twitter is great he bought the place
because he thinks it's so great I think
Twitter's driving him crazy right I
think he's I think he's needlessly
complicated in his life and harming his
reputation and creating a lot of noise
and and harming a lot of other people I
mean so like he the thing that I
objected to with him on Twitter is not
that he bought it and made changes to it
I mean that was not uh again I I remain
agnostic as to whether or not he can
improve the platform
um it was how he was personally behaving
on Twitter not just toward me but toward
the world I think when you
you know forward an article about Nancy
Pelosi's husband being attacked not as
he was by some lunatic but
there's just some gay gay tryst gone
awry right that's not what it seems and
you link to a
a website that previously claimed that
Hillary Clinton was dead and that a body
double was campaigning in her place
that thing was exploding in trumpistan
as a conspiracy theory right and it was
having its effect and it matters that he
was signal boosting it in front of 130
million people and so it is with saying
that you're you know you're you're
former employee yoel Roth is a pedophile
right I was like that has real
consequences it appeared to be complete
[__] and now you could this guy's
getting inundated with death threats
right and Elon that's all that's totally
predictable
right and he's so he's behaving quite
recklessly and there's a long list of
things like like that that he's done on
Twitter
it's not ethical it's not good for him
it's not good for the world it's not
serious it's just it's it's it's a very
adolescent relationship to real problems
in our society and so my my problem with
how he's behaved is that he's
he's purported to touch real issues by
turns like okay do I give the satellites
to Ukraine or not do I do I minimize
their use of them or not is this should
I publicly worry about World War III or
not right he's doing this [__] on
Twitter right and
uh at the same moment he's doing these
other very uh impulsive ill-considered
things and he's not showing any
willingness to really clean up the mess
he makes
um he brings Kanye on knowing he's an
anti-semite who's got mental health
problems and then kicks him off for a
swastika which I probably wouldn't have
kicked him off for a SWAT stickers like
that's that's even like can you really
kick people off for SWAT stickers is
that something that you you get banned
for I mean that are you a free speech
absolutist if you can't let a swa
sticker show up I'm not even sure that's
enforce an enforceable terms of service
right there's their way their moments to
use SWA stickers that are not conveying
hate and not raising they're the risk of
violence clip that yeah any but so much
of what he's doing given that he's again
scale matters he's doing this in front
of 130 million people that's very
different than a million people and
that's very different than a hundred
thousand people and
so when I went off the tracks with Elon
he was doing this about covid and
um again this was a situation where I
tried to privately
mitigate a friend's Behavior
and it didn't work out very well did you
try to correct him sort of highlighting
things he might be wrong on yeah or did
you use the Lex power love method I
should I should write like a pamphlet
for Sam Harris well no but it was it was
totally coming from a place of love
because I was concerned about his
reputation I was concerned about what he
I mean there was a two-fold concern I
could see what was happening with the
tweet I mean he had this original tweet
that was uh
I think it was panic panic over covet is
dumb or something like that right this
is wait this is in March
it's early March uh 2020. oh super early
days super early so when nobody knew
anything but we knew we saw what was
happening in Italy right it was totally
kicking off
um that was a wild time that's when the
toilet paper was totally wild but that
became the most influential tweet on
Twitter for that week I mean it had more
engagement than any other tweet more
than any crazy thing Trump was tweeting
I mean it was it went off
again it was just a nuclear bomb of of
information and I could see that people
were responding to it like
wait a minute okay here's this genius
technologist who must have inside
information about everything right
surely he knows something that is not on
the surface about this pandemic and
they're reading they were reading into
it a lot of information that I knew
wasn't there right and I and at the time
I didn't even I didn't think he had any
reason to be suggesting that I think he
was just firing off a tweet right
so I reached out to him in private and I
mean because it was a private
the text conversation
um I I won't talk about the details but
I'm just saying in that's the case
you know among the many cases of friends
who have public platforms and who did
something that I thought was dangerous
and ill-considered this was a case where
I I reached out in private and tried to
to
um help and genuinely help because it
was just it
I I thought it was harmful in every
sense
because it was being misinterpreted and
it was like okay you can say that panic
over anything is dumb fine but this was
not the how this was landed this was
like non-issue conspiracy there's gonna
be no covet in the U.S it's going to
Peter out it's just going to become a
cold I mean that that's how this was
getting received whereas at that moment
it was absolutely obvious how big a deal
this was going to be no or that it was
going to add minimum going to be a big
deal I don't know if it was obvious but
it was it was obvious that it was a
significant probability that it could be
a big I remember in Mar it was unclear
like how big because there were still
stories of it like it's probably going
to like the big concern the hospital is
my overfilled but it's gonna yeah in
like two months or something yeah we
didn't know but it was there was no way
we weren't going to have
tens of thousands of deaths at a minimum
at that point and and it was it was
every it was totally rational to be
worried about hundreds of thousands and
when Nicholas christakis came on my
podcast very early you know he predicted
quite confidently that we would have
about a million people dead in the U.S
right and
that didn't seem you know it was it was
you know I think appropriately hedged
but it may was still it was just like
okay it's just gonna you just look at
the you we were kind of riding this
exponential and we're and
it's going to be you know it'd be very
surprising not to have that order of
magnitude and not something much much
less and
so anyway I mean again to to close the
the
story on Elon
um I could see how this was being
received and uh I tried to get him to
walk that back and then we we had a
fairly long and detailed uh exchange on
this issue and
that so that intervention didn't
work and it was not done you know I was
not an [__] I was not I was just
concerned you know for him for the world
for and you know
um
and then there are other relationships
where
I didn't take the again that's an
example where taking the time didn't
work right privately
um there are other relations where I
thought okay there's just going to be
more trouble than it's worth and I just
just ignored it you know and there's a
lot of that and I and I Frank again I'm
not comfortable
with how this is all netted out because
I I don't know
if
you know I'm not you know frankly I'm
not comfortable with how much time in
this conversation we've spent talking
about these specific people like what
good is it
for me to to talk about Elon or Brett or
anything I think there's a lot of good
because those friendships listen as a
fan these are the conversations that I I
um loved love is a fan and it feels like
covet has robbed the world of these
conversations
because you are exchanging back and
forth on Twitter but that's not what I
mean by conversations like long form
discussions like a debate about covid
like a normal day but there's no there's
no Elon and I shouldn't be debating
covert you should be here's the thing
with humility like basically saying we
don't really know like the Rogan method
right we don't we're just a bunch of
idiots like one is an engineer you're a
neuroscientist but like it just kind of
okay here's the evidence and be like
normal people that's what everybody was
doing the whole world was like trying to
figure out what the hell what yeah but
the issue was that at that so at the
moment I had this collision with Elon
certain things were not debatable right
it was just it was absolutely clear
where this was going it wasn't clear how
far it was going to go or how quickly we
would mitigate it but it was absolutely
clear that it was going to be an issue
right the the the the train had come off
the tracks in Italy
we knew we weren't going to seal our
borders
and there were already people you know
who there are already cases known to
many of us personally in the U.S at that
point
um
and
he was operating by a very different
logic that I couldn't engage with sure
but the logic represents
a part of the population and there's a
lot of interesting topics that have a
lot of uncertainty around them like the
effectiveness of masks like yeah but no
but where things broke down was not at
the point of oh there's a lot to talk
about a lot to debate this is all very
interesting and who knows what's what it
broke down very early at
this is you know
there's nothing to talk about here like
it like it's like either there's a water
bottle on the table or there isn't right
like
it well technically there's only one
fourth of a water bottle right yeah
so what defines a water bottle is it the
water inside the water bottle is it the
water bottle what I'm giving you is an
example of is worth a conversation
this is difficult because this is we had
an exchange in private and I want to
sure I want to honor not not uh
exposing the details of it but
um
you know the details convinced me that
there was not a follow-up conversation
on that topic on this topic yeah that
said I hope and I hope to be part of
helping that happen the Friendship is
rekindled because one of the topics I
care a lot about artificial intelligence
you're you've had great public and
private conversations about this topic
and yes Elon was very formative in my
taking that issue seriously I mean he
and I went to that initial uh conference
in Puerto Rico together and it was only
because he was going and I found out
about it through him and I just wrote
his coattails to it you know that I that
I got to
dropped in that side of the pool uh to
hear about these concerns at that point
it would be interesting to hear how is
your concerned concern
evolved
with the coming out of Chad GPT
and these uh new large language models
that are fine-tuned with reinforcement
learning and seemingly to be able to do
some incredible human-like things
there's two questions one how is your
concern in terms of AGI and super
intelligence evolved and how impressed
that you would chat gbt as a as a
student of the human mind in mind in
general
well my concern about AGI is unchanged
and so I I did a I've spoken about it a
bunch on my podcast but you know I did a
TED Talk in 2016 which was the the kind
of summary of
what that conference and and you know
various conversations I had after that
did to my my brain on this topic
um basically that once super
intelligence is achieved there's a take
off it becomes exponentially smarter and
in a matter of time there's just we're
ants and they're Gods well yeah unless
we find some way of
dude permanently tethering
a a self a a super intelligent super
intelligent self-improving AI to our
value system and I you know I don't
believe anyone has
figured out how to do that or whether
that's even possible in principle and I
know people like Stuart Russell who I
just had on my podcast
um are oh really have You released it I
haven't released it yet yeah he's been
on previous podcasts but we just
recorded this week because you haven't
done an AI podcast in a while so yeah
it's great yeah he's a good person to
talk about alignment with yeah so Stuart
I mean Stewart is has been you know
probably more than anyone my Guru on
this topic I mean like just reading his
book and doing I think I've done two
podcasts with them at this point I think
it's called the control problem or
something like that his is uh his book
is human compatible human compatible
yeah he talks about the control problem
and
yeah so I just think the idea that we
can define a value function in advance
that permanently tethers a a
self-improving super intelligent AI to
R values as we continue to
discover them refine them extrapolate
them
um in an open-ended way
I think that's a tall order and there I
think there are many more ways there
must be many more ways of Designing
super intelligence that is not aligned
in that way and is not ever
approximating our values in that way so
I mean Stewart's idea to
put it in a very simple way is that
he thinks you don't want to specify the
value function up front you don't you
don't want to imagine you could ever
write the code
in such a way as to admit of no loophole
you want to
make the AI uncertain as to what human
values are and perpetually uncertain and
always trying to ameliorate that
uncertainty by by hewing more and more
closely to what our professed values are
so like this it's always interested in
uh saying oh no no that's not what we
want that's not what we intend stop
doing that right no matter how smart it
gets all it wants to do is more
perfectly approximate human values I
think there are a lot of problems with
that you know at a high level I'm not a
computer scientist so I'm sure there are
many problems at a low level that I
don't understand or like how to force a
human into the loop always no matter
what there's that and like what humans
get a vote and just just what is you
know what what do humans value and what
is the difference between what we say we
value and our revealed preferences which
I mean if you just if you were a super
intelligent AI they could look at
Humanity now
I think you could be forgiven for
concluding that what we value is
driving ourselves crazy with Twitter and
living perpetually on the brink of
nuclear war and you know just watching
you know of hot girls and yoga pants on
Tick Tock again and again and again it's
like when you're saying that is not this
is this is all revealed preference and
it's what is an AI to make of that right
and what should it optimize like so
part of the this is
also Stewart's observation that
one of the Insidious things about like
the YouTube algorithm is it's not that
it just caters
to our preferences it actually begins to
change Us in ways so as to make us more
predictable if I could find ways to make
us a better reporter of our of our
preferences uh and to trim our
preferences down so that it can can uh
further train to that signal so
the main concern is that
most of the people in the field seem not
to be taking
intelligence seriously like as as they
design
more and more intelligent machines and
as they profess to want to design true
AGI
they're not
again they're not spending the time that
Stewart is spending trying to figure out
how to do this safely above all
they're just assuming that these
these problems are going to solve
themselves as we as we make that final
stride into the end zone or they're
saying very
you know pollyannaish things like you
know an AI would never form a motive to
harm human like why would it ever form a
motive to to
be malicious toward Humanity right
unless we put that motive in there right
and that's that's not the concern the
concern is that in the presence of
of vast disparities in competence
and in certainly in a condition where
these the machines are improving
themselves they're improving their own
code they could be developing goal
instrumental goals
that are antithetical to our well-being
without any without any intent to harm
us right it's it's analogous to what we
do to
every other species on Earth I mean you
and I don't consciously form the
intention
to harm insects on a daily basis but
there are many things we could intend to
do that would in fact harm insects
because you know you decide to repave
your driveway or whatever whatever
you're doing you're like you're not
you're just not
taking the the interest of insects into
account because they're so far beneath
you in terms of your cognitive Horizons
and the so that the real challenge here
is that
if you believe that intelligence you
know scales up on a Continuum to toward
Heights that
we can only dimly imagine and I think
there's every reason to believe that
there's no reason to believe that we're
near the summit of intelligence
um and you can Define you know Define
maybe maybe there's
maybe there's some forms of intelligence
for which this is not true but
for for many relevant forms you know
like the top 100 things we care about
cognitively I think there's every reason
to believe that many of those things
most of those things
are a lot like chess or go where once
the machines get better than we are
they're going to stay better than we are
although they're I don't know if you
caught the recent thing with go we're in
this actually came out of Stewart's lab
yeah yeah yeah one time a human beat a
machine and yeah they found a hack for
that but anyway in the ultimately
there's going to be no looking back and
then the question is
what do you what do we do in relate in
relationship to these systems that are
more competent than we are in every
relevant respect because it will be a
relationship it's not like the people
the people who think we're just going to
figure this all out
you know without thinking about it in
advance it's just gonna these the
solutions are just going to find
themselves
um
seem not to be taking
the prospect of really creating
autonomous super intelligence seriously
like like what does that mean it's every
bit as
independent and ungovernable ultimately
as us having create I mean just imagine
if we created a race of people that were
10 times smarter than all of us like how
would we live with those people they're
10 times smarter than us right like they
begin to talk about things we don't
understand they begin to want things we
don't understand they begin to view us
as obstacles to them so they're solving
those problems we're gratifying those
desires
we become the chickens or the monkeys in
their presence and
I think that
it's but for some amazing solution of
the sort that Stuart is is imagining
that we could somehow anchor their
reward function permanently no matter
how intelligent scales I think um it's
it's really worth worrying about this I
do I do buy the the you know the Sci-Fi
uh notion that this is an existential
risk if we don't do it well I worry that
we don't notice it
I'm I'm deeply impressed with Chad GPT
and I'm worried that it will become
super intelligent these language models
will become super intelligent because
they're basically trained in the
collective intelligence of the human
species and then it will start
controlling our Behavior if they're
integrated into our algorithms
the recommender systems and then we just
won't notice
that there's a super intelligent system
that's controlling our Behavior
well I think that's true even before far
before super intelligence even before
general intelligence I mean I think just
the narrow intelligence
of these algorithms and of what
something like you know chat GPT can can
do
um
I mean it's just
far
short of it developing its own goals and
that is that are at Cross purposes with
ours just the just the unintended
consequences of of using it in the ways
we're going to be incentivized to use it
and and you know the money to be made
from scaling this thing and what it does
to to our information space and our
sense of of just being able to get the
ground truth of
on any facts it's um
yeah it's it's super scary and it was
it's do you think it's a giant leap in
terms of the development towards AGI
child GPT or we still
um this is just an impre impressive
little
toolbox so like what do you think the
singularity is coming
or is it to you it doesn't matter
eventually I have no intuitions on that
front apart from the fact that if we
continue to make progress it will come
right so it's just you just have to
assume we continue to make progress
there's only two assumptions you you
have to assume substrate Independence so
there's no reason why this can't be done
in silico it's it's just we can build
arbitrarily intelligent machines
there's nothing magical about having
having this done in in the wet wear of
our own brains
I think that is true and I think that's
a you know scientifically parsimony is
to think that that's true
um and then you just have to assume
we're going to keep making progress it
doesn't have to be any special rate of
progress doesn't have to be Moore's Law
it can just be we just keep going at a
certain point we're going to be in
relationship to Minds leaving
Consciousness Consciousness aside I I
don't I don't have any reason to believe
that
they'll necessarily be conscious by
virtue of being super intelligent and
that's its own interesting ethical
question but
uh
leaving conscience aside
they're going to be more they're going
to be more competent than we are and
then that's like you know the aliens
have landed you know that's literally
that's an encounter
with again leaving aside the possibility
that that something like Stewart's
path is is is
actually available to us
but it is hard to picture
if what we mean by intelligence All
Things Considered and it's truly General
um
if that scales and
you know begins to
build upon itself how you
maintain
that perfect slavish devotion Until the
End of Time the tethering those systems
that tell us to humans yeah I think uh
my gut says that that tether is not oh
there's a lot of ways to do it so it's
not this increasingly impossible problem
right so I have no you know you know as
you know I'm not a computer scientist I
have no intuitions about just
algorithmically how you would approach
that and what's possible my main
intuition is uh maybe deeply flawed but
the main intuition is based on the fact
that most of the learning is currently
happening on human knowledge
so even Chad GPT is just trained on
human data right
I I don't see where the takeoff happens
where you completely go above human
wisdom the current impressive aspect of
child gpts that's using collective
intelligence of all of us
from what what I gleaned from again from
people who know much more about this
than I do I
I think we have reason to be skeptical
that these techniques of you know deep
learning
are actually going to be sufficient to
push us into AGI right so it's just not
they're not
they're not generalizing in the way they
need to they're not certainly not
learning like human children and so
they're they're
there's brittle and strange ways they're
they're
um it's not to say that the human path
is the only path you know and you know
and maybe there's we might learn better
lessons by ignoring the way brains work
but
um
we know that they don't generalize and
use
abstraction the way we do and so
um although they have strange holes in
their competence but the size of the
holes is shrinking every time and that's
so the intuition starts to slowly fall
apart you know the intuition is like
surely it can't be this simple to
achieve super intelligence yeah but it's
becoming simpler and simpler so I don't
know I don't the progress is quite
incredible I've been extremely
impressive Chad GPT and the new models
and there's a lot of financial incentive
to make progress on this regard so it's
we're going to be living through some
very interesting times uh
in raising a question that I'm going to
be talking to you A lot of people
brought up this topic probably because
Eric Weinstein talked to Joe Rogan
recently and said that he and you were
contacted by folks about UFOs uh can you
clarify the nature of this contact
yeah yeah that you were in contact about
I've got very little to say on this I
mean he has much more to say I think he
I think he went down this Rabbit Hole
further than than I did um
which wouldn't surprise anyone
um he's got much more of a taste for
this sort of thing than I do but I think
we're contacted by the same person
it wasn't clear to me who this person
was or how this person got that my cell
phone number
um
they didn't seem
uh it didn't seem like we were getting
punked I mean the person seemed credible
to me
and they were talking to you about the
release of different videos on you yeah
and this this is when there was a flurry
of activity around this so there was
like there was a big New Yorker article
on on UFOs and there was there was a
the rumors of Congressional hearings I
think come in and
if and then with the the videos that uh
were being debunked or not
um
and so this person contacted both of us
I think around the same time and I think
he might have contacted Rogan or other
Eric is just the only person I've spoken
to about it I think
um who I know was contacted and
the um
what happened is the person kept you
know writing a check that he didn't cash
like he kept saying okay next week I'm
gonna you know I understand this is
sounding spooky and you know you have no
reason to really trust me but uh next
week I'm gonna I'm gonna put you on a
zoom call with people who you will
recognize and they're going to be you
know former heads of the CIA and you
know people people who just you're gonna
within five seconds of being on the zoom
call you'll you'll know this is not a
hoax uh so great just let me know just
send me the zoom link right and I went
that happened maybe three times you know
there was just one phone conversation
and then it was just texts you know
there's just a bunch of texts and I
think uh Eric spent more time with this
person and I'm not I haven't spoken
about I know he spoke about it publicly
but
um
so I you know it's not that my [__]
detector ever
really went off in a big way it's just
the thing never happened and I so I lost
interest so you made a comment which is
interesting that you ran the which I
really appreciate that you ran the
thought experiment of saying okay maybe
we do have alien spacecraft or just the
thought of experiment the aliens did
visit yeah and then
this is a very kind of nihilistic sad
thought that it wouldn't matter
it wouldn't affect your life can you can
you explain that well no I would I
always I think many people
noticed this I mean this was a sign of
how crazy the news cycle was at that
point right like we had coveted and we
had Trump and I forget when this the UFO
thing was really kicking off but
uh it just seemed like no one had the
bandwidth to even be interested in this
it's like I I was amazed to
notice in myself
that I wasn't more interested in
figuring out what was going on it's like
and I I considered okay wait a minute
this is if this is true this is the
biggest story in anyone's lifetime I
mean contact with alien intelligence
is by definition the biggest story in
anyone's lifetime in in human history
um
why isn't this just
totally captivating and it Not only was
it not totally captivating it was just
barely rising to the level of
my being able to pay attention to it and
I I view that I mean one as a
um
to some degree a an understandable
defense mechanism against the the
bogus claims that that have been made
about this kind of thing in the past
um
you know the general sense is probably
[__] or it probably has some
explanation that just you know purely
terrestrial and not surprising and there
was there's there is somebody who
what's his name is Mick West I forget is
it the YouTuber yes yeah he debunk stuff
yeah he don't I mean I you know I I have
since seen some of those videos I mean
now now this is going back still at
least a year but some of those videos
seem like fairly credible debunkings of
some of the the optical evidence
um
and I'm surprised we don't haven't seen
more of that like there was a
a fairly credulous 60 Minutes piece that
came out around that time looking at
some of that video and it was the very
video that he was debunking on YouTube
and you know his his video only had like
50 000 views on it or whatever
um
but again it seemed like a fairly
credible debunking I haven't seen
debunkings of his debunkings but uh I
think there is but he's basically saying
that there is there is possible
explanations for it right and usually in
these kinds of contexts if there's a
possible explanation even if it seems
unlikely
is going to be more likely than an alien
civilization visiting us yeah it's the
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence principle which I
I think is generally true well with
aliens I think generally
I think there should be some humility
about what they would look like when
they show up but I tend to think they're
already here the amazing thing about
this AI conversation though is that
we're talking about a circumstance where
we would be designing the aliens yeah
and they would and there's every reason
to believe that eventually this is going
to happen like I said I'm not at all
skeptical about
the the coming reality of the aliens and
we're going to build them now here's the
thing does this apply to when super
intelligence shows up
will this be trending on Twitter for a
day and then we'll go on to complain
about
something Sam Harris once again said in
his podcast you you tend to trend on
Twitter even though you're not on
Twitter which is great yeah uh I don't I
haven't noticed I might I did I did
notice when I was on but um do you have
this concern about
uh AGI basically same kind of thing that
we would just look the other way is
there something about this time where
even like world war three which has been
throwing around very casually
concerningly so even that the new cycle
wipes that away yeah well I I think we
have this
this General problem that we can't make
certain information even
you know
unequivocally certain information
emotionally
Salient like like we we respond quite
readily to certain things I mean as we
talked about we respond to the
the little girl who fell down a well I
mean that just that gets 100 of our
emotional resources but
the abstract probability that of nuclear
war right even a high probability even
just even an intolerable probability
even if we put it at
30 percent right you know like it's just
like that's
a Russian roulette with a you know gun
with three chambers and you know it's
aimed at the heads not only your head
but your kid's head and everyone's kid's
head and it's just 24 hours a day and
um
I mean I think people who who this
pre-ukraine I think the people who have
made it their business to
you know professionally to think about
the risk of nuclear war and to mitigate
it you know people like Graham Allison
or William Perry or
I think they were putting like the the
ongoing risk I mean just the risk that
we're going to have if a proper nuclear
war at some point in the you know the
Next Generation
people were putting it at something like
50 right they were living with this sort
of Damocles over our heads now you might
wonder whether
anyone can have reliable intuitions
about the probability of that kind of
thing but
the the status quo is truly alarming I
mean we've got you know we've got icbms
on Leaf aside smaller exchanges and you
know tactical nukes and how that could
how we could have a World War
you know based on you know incremental
changes we've got
the biggest bombs aimed at the biggest
cities in both directions
and it's old technology right and it's
you know and it's
vulnerable to some lunatic deciding to
launch or or misreading you know bad
data and we know we've been saved from
nuclear war
I think at least twice by
you know Soviet submarine commanders
deciding I'm not going to pass this up
to change a chain of command right it's
like this is
it's almost certainly an error and it
turns out it wasn't error it's like like
and we we need people
to I mean in that particular case like
he saw I think it was five
what seemed like five missiles launched
from the US to Russia and he reasoned if
the if America was going to engage in a
first strike they'd launch more than
five missiles right so this this has to
be fictional and then he waited long
enough to decide that it was fictional
but the probability of of
a nuclear war Happening by mistake or in
some other species of inadvertence you
know misunderstanding uh
technical malfunction
that's intolerable forget about the the
intentional use of it by by people who
are you know
Driven Crazy by some ideology
and more and more Technologies are
enabled a kind of scale of Destruction
and misinformation plays into this
picture
in a way that is
especially scary I mean once you can get
a deep fake of
you know the any current president of
the United States claiming to have
launched a first strike you know and
just
you know send that everywhere but they
can change the nature of Truth and then
we that might change the
um the engine we have for skepticism
is sharpen it
and digital watermarks that help us
maybe we'll not trust any information
that hasn't come through
uh specific channels right I mean so
like in in my world
it's like
I I no longer feel the the need to resp
you know respond to anything other than
what I put out in in my channels of
information it's like there's there's so
much there are so many people who have
clipped stuff of me that shows the
opposite of what I was actually saying
in context I mean the people have like
re-edited my podcast audio to make it
seem like I said the opposite of what I
was saying it's like unless I put it out
you know you can't be sure that I
actually said it you know I mean it's
it's just uh
but I don't know what it's like to live
like that for all forms of information
and uh I mean Strangely I think it may
require a
a greater siloin of information in the
end you know it's like it it it's uh
we're living through this sort of wild
west period where everyone's got a
newsletter and everyone's got a Blog and
everyone's got an opinion but once you
can fake everything there might be
greater value for expertise yeah for
experts but a more rigorous system for
identifying who the experts are yeah or
just or just knowing that you know it's
going to be an arms race to
authenticate information so it's like if
if you can never trust a photograph
yeah unless it has been vetted by Getty
Images
because only Getty Images has the
resources to to authenticate the
provenance of that photograph and then a
test that hasn't been meddled with by AI
um and again I don't even know if that's
technically possible and maybe the
whatever the tools
available for this will be you know
commodified and and the cost will be
driven to zero so quickly that everyone
will be able to do it you know it could
be like encryption but and it would be
proven and tested most effectively first
of course as always in porn
yeah which is where most of human
innovation technology happens first
um well I have to ask because Ron Howard
the director asked us on Twitter since
we're talking about the threat of
nuclear war and otherwise he asked I'd
be interested in both your expectations
for Human Society if when we move Beyond
Mars
with those societies be industrial based
how will it be governed how will
criminal infractions be dealt with
when you read or watch Sci-Fi what comes
closest to sounding logical do you think
about our society beyond Earth
if economize Mars if a colonized space
yeah well I think I have a pretty
a humbling picture of that so because
we're still going to be the Apes that we
are so we when you when you imagine
colonizing Mars you have to imagine a
first fist fight on Mars you have to
imagine first murder on Mars also
infidelity yeah somebody extramarital
Affairs on Mars right so it's gonna get
uh really homely and boring really fast
I think you know it's like only the
spacesuits or whatever the other uh
extinguencies of just living in that
atmosphere or lack thereof uh will limit
how badly we can behave on Mars but do
you think most of the interaction will
be still in Meet Space versus digital do
you think there will be do you think
we're like living through a
transformation of a kind
where we're going to be doing more and
more interaction than digital space
like everything we've been complaining
about Twitter
is it possible that Twitter's just the
early days of a broken system that's
actually uh giving birth to a better
working system that's ultimately digital
I think we're gonna
experience a pendulum swing back into
the real world I mean I think many of us
are experiencing that now anyway I'm
just just wanting to
have face to face encounters and spend
less time on our phones and less time
online I think you know maybe everyone
isn't going in that direction but
I do notice it myself and I notice
I mean once I got off Twitter then I
noticed the people who were never on
Twitter right and then and the people
who are never basically I mean I know I
have a lot of friends who are never on
Twitter yeah and they actually never
understood what I was doing on Twitter
it's like like they just like it wasn't
that they were seeing it and then
reacting to it they just didn't know
it's like
it's like being on riff like I'm not on
Reddit either but I don't spend any time
thinking about not being on Reddit right
it's like I just I'm just not on Reddit
um do you think the pursuit of human
happiness is better achieved more
effectively achieved outside of
Twitter world
well I I think all we have is our
attention in the end and we just have to
notice what these various tools are
doing to it and
it's just it became very clear to me
that
it was an unrewarding use of my
attention now it's not to say there
isn't some digital platform that's
conceivable that would be
useful but
um and rewarding but
yeah I mean we just have
you know our life is doled out to us in
moments and we we have and we're
continually solving this riddle of
what is going to suffice to make this
moment engaging and meaningful and
aligned with
who I want to be now and how I want the
future to to look right and it's that we
have this tension between being in the
present and becoming in the future
and um
you know it's a seeming Paradox again
it's not really a paradox but it can see
it like I do think the ground truth
for personal well-being
is to find a mode of being where
you can pay attention
to the present moment and this is you
know meditation by another name
you can pay attention to the present
moment with sufficient you know gravity
that you recognize that that just
Consciousness itself in the present
moment no matter what's happening
is already a circumstance of freedom and
and contentment and and Tranquility like
you can be happy now before anything
happens before this next desire gets
gratified before this next problem gets
solved there's a there's this kind of
ground truth that that you're free that
Consciousness is free and open and
unencumbered by really any problem until
you get lost and thought about all the
problems that may yet be real for you so
the ability to catch and observe
Consciousness that in itself is a source
of Happiness without being lost in
thought and and so what what this
happened this happens
haphazardly for people who don't
meditate because they'll find something
in their life that's so captivating
it's so pleasurable it's so uh thrilling
it can even be scary but it can be
even being scared is captivated like so
it gets it gets their attention right
whatever it is if you like you know
Sebastian younger or you know was wrote
a great book about
people's experience in war here you know
it's like like you can strangely it can
be the best experience anyone's ever had
because everything it's like only the
moment matters right like the bullet is
whizzing by your head you're not
thinking about your your 401k or that
thing that you didn't say last week to
the person you shouldn't have been
talking about you're not thinking about
Twitter it's like you're just fully
immersed in the present moment
um
meditation is the only way I mean the
the that word can mean many things to
many people but what I mean by
meditation is simply the discovery that
there is a a
way to
engage the present moment directly
regardless of what's happening and you
don't need to be in a war you don't need
to be having sex you don't need to be on
drugs you don't need to be surfing you
don't need nothing it doesn't have to be
a peak experience it can be completely
ordinary but you can recognize that in
some basic sense there's only this and
and everything else is something you're
thinking you're thinking about the past
you're thinking about the future and
thoughts themselves have no substance
right it's it's fundamentally mysterious
that any thought
ever really commandeers your sense of
who you are and and makes you anxious or
afraid or or angry or whatever it is
um and the more you discover that the
half-life of all these negative emotions
that blow all of us around
get much much shorter right and you can
you can literally just you know the the
anger that would have kept you angry for
hours or days
lasts you know four seconds because you
just the moment it arises you recognize
it and you can get off that you can
decide at minimum you can decide whether
it's useful to stay angry at that moment
and you know obviously it usually isn't
and the illusion of Free Will is one of
those thoughts yeah it's all just
happening right like even the Mindful
and meditative response to this it's
just happening and happening it's just
like even
the moments where you recognize or not
recognize is just happening it's not
that the the
this does open up a degree of freedom
for a person but it's not a freedom that
gives any motivation to the notion of
free will it's just a new
way of being in the world is there a
difference between intellectually
annoying Free Will as an illusion and
really experiencing it yeah what's the
what's the longest you've been able to
experience the escape the illusion if
you will well it's always I it's always
obvious to me when I pay attention I
mean when I whenever I'm mindful the the
term of jargon you know in the Buddhist
and and increasingly you know outside
the Buddhist context is is mindfulness
right but they're sort of different
levels of mindfulness and there's
there's different um
degrees of insight into this but yes I
mean what I'm calling evidence of lack
of Free Will and lack of you know lack
of the self and I got two sides of the
same coin there's a sense of being
a subject in the middle of experience to
whom all experience refers the sense of
I the sense of me
and that's almost everybody's starting
point when they they start to meditate
and that's almost always the place
people live most of their lives from I
do think that gets interrupted in ways
that get unrecognized I think people are
constantly losing the sense of I they're
losing the sense of subject object
distance
but they're not recognizing it and and
meditation is
the mode in which you can recognize you
can you can both consciously precipitate
it you can look for the self and fail to
find it and then recognize its absence
and that's the just the flip side of the
coin of free will I mean the the the the
feeling of having free will is what it
feels like to feel like a self
who's thinking his thoughts and doing
his actions and intending his intentions
and he the the man in the middle of the
boat who's Rowan
um
that's the story that's the false
starting point when you find that
there's no one in the middle of the boat
right or in fact there's no boat there's
just the river there's just the flow of
experience
and there's no Center to it and there's
no place from which you would control it
again even when you're doing things this
does not negate the difference between
voluntary and involuntary Behavior it's
like
I can voluntarily reach for this but
when I'm paying attention I'm aware that
everything is just happening like just
the intention to move is just Horizon
right and
I'm in no position I don't know why it
didn't arise a moment before or a moment
later or a moment or or you know
50 stronger or weaker or you know so as
to be ineffective or to be doubly
effective where I lurched for it versus
I move slow I mean I'm not
yeah I can never run the counter
factuals I can never all this opens the
door to a
and even more disconcerting picture
along the same lines which is
subsumes this conversation about Free
Will and it's the question of whether
anything is ever possible like what if
this is a question I I haven't thought a
lot of about it but
it's been a few years I've been kicking
this question around
um
so I mean what if only the actual
is possible would it what if there was
what if it was do we live with this
feeling of possibility we live with a
sense that
let me tell you so you know I have two
daughters
I could have had a third child right so
what does it mean to say that I could
have had a third child all right so do
you you don't have kids I don't think so
not that I know of yes so the
possibility might be there so what do we
mean when we say
you could have had a child or
you might you you might have a child in
the future like what what what is the
space in real what's the relationship
between possibility and actuality and
reality is there a reality in which
non-actual things
are nonetheless real and so there we
have other categories of like non
concrete things we have things that
don't have spatial temporal Dimension
but they're nonetheless they they
nonetheless exist so like you know in
the integers right so numbers
there's a there's a reality there's an
abstract reality to numbers and this is
it's philosophically interesting to
think about these things so they're not
like in some sense they're
they're they're real
and they're just they're not merely
invented by us they're discovered
because they have structure that we
can't impose upon them right it's not
like they're not fictional characters
like you know I mean Hamlet and Superman
also exist in some sense but they exist
at the level of of Our Own
fiction and abstraction but it's like
they're true they're true and false
statements you can make about Hamlet
they're true and false statements you
can make about Superman because our
fiction the fictional worlds we've
created have a certain kind of structure
but again this is all abstract it's like
it's all abstractable from any of its
concrete instantiations it's not just in
the comic books and just in the movies
it's in our you know ongoing ideas about
these characters
but natural numbers or
um
the integers don't
function quite that way I mean they're
similar but they also have a structure
that's purely a matter of Discovery it's
not you can't just make up whether
numbers are prime
you know if you give me two integers you
know of a certain size to let's you
mentioned two enormous integers
if I were to say okay well between those
two integers they're exactly 11 prime
numbers right that's a very specific
Claim about which I can be right or
wrong and whether or not anyone knows
I'm right or it's like that's just
there's a domain of facts there these
are abstract it's an abstract reality
that relates in some way that's
philosophically interesting you know
metaphysically interesting too
what we call real reality you know this
the spatial temporal order
the physics of things
but
possibility at least in my view occupies
a different space and this is something
again I my thoughts on this are pretty
in co-ed I I think I need to talk to
a philosopher of physics and and or a
physicist about how this may interact
with with things like the many worlds
interpretation yeah that's an
interesting right right exactly so I I
wonder if discover is in physics like
further proof or more concrete proof
that many world's interpretation of
quantum mechanics has some validity
right if that completely starts to
change things but even if that that's
just more
actuality so if I took that seriously ah
sure that's that's a case of
and and Truth is that happens even even
if the many worlds interpretation isn't
true but we just imagine we have a
physically infinite universe
the implication of infinity is such that
things will begin to repeat themselves
you know the farther you go in space
right so the you know if
if you just head out in One Direction
eventually you're going to meet two
people just like us having a
conversation just like this and you're
going to meet them an infinite number of
times in every you know infinite variety
of permutations slightly different from
this conversation right so I mean
Infinity is just so big that our
intuitions of probability completely
break down
but what I'm suggesting is
maybe probability isn't a thing right
maybe there's only actuality if there's
maybe there's only what happens
and at every point along the way
our notion of what could have happened
or what might have happened is just that
it's just a thought about what could
have happened or there's no so it's a
fundamentally different thing if you can
imagine a thing that doesn't make it
real
so they because that's that's where that
possibility exists in your imagination
yeah and and possibility itself is a
kind of spooky idea because it it too
has a sort of structure
right so like if I if I'm going to say
you know
you could have had a daughter right last
year
um
so we're saying that's that's possible
but not actual
right that is a claim they're things
that
are true and not true
about that daughter right like that it
has a kind of structure it's like
I feel like there's a lot of fog around
that the possibility it feels like
almost like a useful narrative but what
does it mean so like
what does it mean if if we say you know
I just did that but I'm it's conceivable
that I wouldn't have done that right
like it's possible that I I just threw
this cap but I might not have done that
so you're taking it very temporarily
close to the original like what would
appear as a decision
whenever we're saying something's
possible but not actual right like this
thing just happened but it's conceived
it's possible that it wouldn't have
happened or that would have happened
differently
in what does that possibility
consist like where is that what it for
that to be real for the possibility to
be real
what do we what claim are we making
about
the universe well isn't that an
extension of the idea that Free Will is
an illusion that all we have is
sexuality that the possibility isn't
right yeah I'm just extending it Beyond
is there human action uh like it's it
this goes to the physics of things this
is just everything like we're always
telling ourselves a story yeah that
includes possibility possibility is
really compelling for some reason
well yeah well because it's it's
I mean so this yeah I mean this could
sound just academic but it every
backward looking regret or
disappointment
and every forward-looking worry
is completely dependent on this notion
of possibility like every regret is
based on the sense that something else I
could have done something else something
else could have happened every
disposition to worry about the future
is based on the feeling that there's
this range of possibilities it could go
either way
and
you know I I know whether whether or not
there's such a thing as possibility you
know I'm convinced that worry is Almost
Never
psychologically
appropriate because the reality is in
any given moment
either you can do something to solve the
problem you're worried about or not so
if you can do something just do it you
know and if you can't you're worrying is
just causing you to suffer twice over
right you're gonna
you know you're gonna you're gonna get
the medical procedure next week anyway
how much time between now and next week
do you want to spend worrying about it
right it's gonna it's the worry the
worry doesn't accomplish anything how
much do physicists think about
possibility well they think about it in
terms of probability
more often but probability just
describes
and again this is a place where I'm I
might be out of my depth and need to
talk to somebody to to uh debunk this
but the um do therapy with a physicist
yeah um but probably it seems just
describes a pattern of actuality that
we've observed
right I mean we have there are certain
things we observe
and those are the actual things that
have happened
and we have this additional story about
probability I mean is that we have the
frequency with which things happen have
happened in the past
um
you know I can flip a Fair coin and know
I know in the abstract that I have a
belief that in the limit that those
flips the you know those tosses should
Converge on 50 heads and 50 Tails I know
I have a story as to why it's not going
to be exactly 50 within any
arbitrary time frame
um
but in reality all we ever have are the
observed tosses
right and then we have an additional
story that oh it came up heads but it
could have come up tails
why do we think that
about that last toss
and and what are we claiming is true
about the physics of things
if we say it could have been otherwise I
think we're claiming that probability is
true
that that just it allows us to
have a nice model about the world it
gives us hope about the world yeah it
seems that possibility has to be
somewhere to be effective it's a little
it's a little bit like what's what's
happening with the laws there's
something metaphysically interesting
about the laws of nature too because the
laws of nature so the laws of nature
impose their their work on the world
right we see their evidence
but they're not reducible to any
specific set of instances right so
there's some structure there
but the structure isn't
just a matter of the actual things with
the actual billiard balls that are
banging into each other
all of that actuality can be explained
by what actual things are actually doing
but then we have this notion that in
addition to that we have the laws of
nature that are making they're
explaining this act but but how are the
laws of nature an additional thing
in addition to just the actual things
that are actually effect costly and if
they're if they are an additional thing
in how are they effective if not they're
not among the actual things that are
just actually banging around yeah and so
to some degree for that possible
possibly has to be hiding somewhere for
the laws of nature to be possible
for anything to be possible it has to be
it has to have closets somewhere I'm
sure it's just where all the possibility
goes it has to be attached to something
so you don't think many worlds is that
yeah because maybe once it still exists
well because we're in this strand of
that Multiverse yeah right so it's still
still you have just a local instance of
what is actual yeah and then if it
proliferates elsewhere where you can't
be affected by it many worlds as well
you can't really connect with the other
yeah yeah and so many worlds is just a
statement of
basically everything that can happen
happens somewhere
right that's yeah you know and that's I
mean maybe that's not an entirely kosher
formulation of it but it it seems pretty
close so so but there's whatever happens
right in fact there's you know
relativistically there's a
there's a you know the the Einstein's
original notion of a block universe
seems to suggest this and I it's been a
while since I've been in a conversation
with a physicist where I've gotten a
chance to ask about the standing of this
concept in physics currently I don't
hear it discuss much but the idea of a
block universe is that you know the
space-time
exists as a totality in our sense that
we are traveling
through space-time
where there's a real difference between
the past and the future
that that's an illusion of just our you
know
you know weird the weird the weird slice
we're taking of of this larger object
but on some level
it's like you know you're reading a
novel The last page of the novel exists
just as much as the first page when
you're in the middle of it and they're
just
you know if that's if we're living in
anything like that then there's no such
thing as
possibility I I would it would seem this
just
what is actual so
as a matter of our experience moment to
moment
I think it's totally compatible with
that being true that there is only what
is actual and
that sounds to the the naive ear that
sounds like it would be depressing and
disempowering and confining
but as anything but it's actually it's a
circumstance of pure Discovery like you
have no idea what's going to happen next
right you don't know who you're going to
be tomorrow you're only by tendency
seeming to resemble yourself from
yesterday and there's there's way more
freedom in all of that than than it
seems true to many people and
yet
the basic Insight is that you're not
you're not in the the real freedom is is
the recognition that you're not in
control of anything everything is just
happening including your thoughts and
intentions and moves so life is a is a
process of continuous Discovery you're
part of the universe yeah you are you
are just this I mean it's
it's the miracle that the the universe
is illuminated to itself as itself where
you sit and you're and you're
continually discovering
what your life is
and then you're you have this layer at
which you're telling yourself a story
that you already know what your life is
and you know exactly you know who you
should be and what's you know what's
about to happen or you're struggling to
form a confident opinion about all of
that and yet there is this this
fundamental mystery to everything even
the most familiar experience
we're all NPCs in the most marvelous
video game
maybe although my my game my sense of
gaming is does not run as deep as to
know what I'm committing to there's a
non it's a non-plane character you're
more yeah oh wow yes you're more you're
more of a Mario Kart guy yeah yeah I
went back I was in an original video
gamer but it's been a long time since I
I mean I was I was there for pong I
remember when I saw the first pong in a
restaurant in uh
and he was like Benihana's or something
they had a pong and a table and that was
an amazing amazing moment when he was
you Sam harrisman I lived from pong
to the invention and deployment of a
super intelligent system yeah well that
that happened fast if it happens anytime
in my lifetime from from pong to AGI uh
what kind of things do you do purely for
fun that others might consider a waste
of time
purely for fun
because meditation doesn't count because
most people say that's not a waste of
time is there something like pong
that's a deeply embarrassing thing you
would never admit
I don't think well I mean once or twice
a year I will play a round of golf which
many people would find embarrassing uh
they might even find my play
embarrassing but uh do you find it
embarrassing no I mean I I love golf
just takes way too much time so I can
only squander a certain amount of time
on it I I do love it it's a lot of fun
well you have no control over your
actual performance you're you're ever
discovering I I do I do have I have
control over my mediocre performance but
it's uh I don't have enough controllers
to make it really good
but happily I don't I I'm in the perfect
spot because I don't invest enough time
in it to care how I play so I just have
fun when I play well I I hope there'll
be a day where you play around golf with
the former president Donald Trump and I
would uh I would bet on him if we played
golf I'm sure he's a better golfer
amidst the chaos of human civilization
in modern times as we've talked about
what gives you hope
about this world in the coming
here in the coming decade in the coming
hundred years maybe a thousand years
what's the source of Hope for you
well it comes back to a few of the
things we've talked about I think I'm
I'm hopeful I I know that most people
are good and are mostly
converging on the same core values right
it's like we're not surrounded by
Psychopaths and
I um the thing that
finally convinced me to to get off
Twitter was how different life was
seeming through the lens of Twitter it's
like I just got the sense that there's
way more Psychopaths or effective
Psychopaths than I realized and then I
thought okay that's this isn't real this
is this is either a strange context in
which actually decent people are
behaving like Psychopaths or it's um you
know it's a bot army or something that I
don't have to take seriously so
yeah I just think most people
if we can get the if we can get the
incentives right
I think there's no reason why we can't
really Thrive collectively like so
there's enough wealth to go around
there's enough
you know there's no
there's no effective limit you know I
mean again within the limits of what's
physically possible but we're nowhere
near the limit
on abundance
you know on this I forget about going to
Mars on this the one Rock right it's
like we we could make this place
incredibly beautiful uh and stable if we
just
did enough work to
solve some you know you know rather uh
long-standing political problems in the
problem of incentives so that to you the
the basic characteristics of human
nature such that we'll be okay if the
incentives are okay
we'll do it we'll do pretty good
I'm worried about the asymmetry is that
it's easier to break things than to fix
them it's easier to
to um
light a fire than to put it out and
uh
I do worry that you know as technology
gets more and more powerful it becomes
easier for the minority who wants to
screw things up to effectively screw
things up for everybody right so it's
easier it's like it
a thousand years ago it was simply
impossible for one person to
derange the lives of millions much less
billions
now that's getting to be possible
so on the assumption that we're always
going to have a sufficient number of
crazy individuals or or
malevolent individuals it's it's uh
that is we have to figure out that
asymmetry somehow and so there's some
cautious exploration of emergent
technology that we need to get
our our head screw on straight about so
like so gain a function research like
just how much do we want to democratize
uh you know all the relevant
Technologies there you know do we want
really you really want to give everyone
the ability to order nucleotides in the
mail and and give them the blueprints
for viruses online because of you know
you're a free speech absolutist and you
think all PDFs need to be
uh you know exportable everywhere
um
so much more so this is where yeah so
there are limits to
many people are confused about my take
on Free Speech because I've come down on
on
the unpopular side of some of these
questions but
it's been my overriding concern is that
in in many cases I'm worried about the
free speech of
the individual businesses or individual
platforms or individual you know media
people
to decide that they don't want to be
associated with certain things right so
like if if you own Twitter I think you
should be able to kick off the not so
you don't want to be associated with
because it's your platform you own it
right that's your free speech
right that's the side of my free speech
concern for Twitter right it's not that
every Nazi has the right to to be to
algorithmic speech on Twitter I think if
you own Twitter you should be you or the
you know whether it's just Elon or you
know in the world where it wasn't Elon
just the people who own Twitter the the
and the board and the shareholders and
the employees
these people need to just can should be
free to decide what they want to promote
or not their public I view them as
Publishers more you know more than as as
Platforms in the end and
um that has other implications
but
I do worry about this problem of
misinformation and
algorithmically and otherwise you know
supercharged misinformation
and
I think
I do think we have we're at a bottleneck
now I mean I guess it could be the
hubris of every present generation to
think that their moment is especially
important but I do think with the
emergence of these Technologies
or some kind of bottleneck where we
really have to figure out how to get
this right and if we do get this right
if we figure out how to not drive
ourselves Crazy by giving people access
to all the all possible information and
misinformation at all times
I think yeah we could there's no limit
to how
happily we could collaborate with
billions of creative fulfilled people
you know it's just and trillions of uh
robots some of them sex robots but
that's another robots that have are
running the right algorithm whatever
that algorithm is whatever you need in
your life to make you happy so
um um I was the first time we talked is
one of the huge honors of my life I've
been a fan of yours for a long time the
few times you were respectful but
critical to me means the world and thank
you so much for helping
um helping me and caring enough and
caring enough about the world and for
everything you do but I should say that
the few of us that try to put love in
the world on Twitter miss you on Twitter
but yes enjoy yourselves
don't don't break anything have a good
party without me thanks so much uh very
very happy to do this thanks thanks for
the invitation thank you great to see
you again
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Sam Harris to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from Martin
Luther King Jr
love is the only Force capable of
transforming an enemy into a friend
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time